Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Auf Wiedersehen!
Für's Zuschauen!
Malen, Nachtzahlen und Blumen auf Fritz, hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio, das jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat stattfindet. Unter dem immer Gäste vom Chaos Computer Club, naja Gäste ist eigentlich, zu viel gesagt, eigentlich übernehmen die das hier alle und dann machen sie komische Dinge. Heute sehr seltsamer Gestalt mit einem komischen Akzent. Herzlich willkommen ihr beiden, ihr seid bitte wer?
Hallo, it's me, Mario. Wir erzählen heute über das Rohrsystem, das das Internet darstellt.
Dieser komische Rohrvergleich, dass das Internet ein Rohrsystem ist, der kann doch von irgendeinem nichts wissenden amerikanischen Politiker, oder?
Genau, der meinte, das Internet wäre a series of tubes.
Genau und das wollen wir heute tatsächlich mal aufklären, dass es nicht so ist. Aber dennoch hat es was mit Röhren zu tun, nämlich mit der Klempnerei. Das heißt, da sitzen ja Leute dahinter, die dieses Ding irgendwie kontrollieren. Wir wollen heute mal erklären, was passiert eigentlich, wenn das Datenpaket von eurem Rechner die Steckdose in eurer Wohnung durchbricht und dann in dieses komische Internet daraus geht. Wir erklären also das Internet, aber nein, nicht technisch, sondern ökonomisch eigentlich, oder? Also sagen, wer sitzt da als Firma oder als Beteiligter mit dahinter und verdient da wie Geld? Und wer muss wo Geld kriegen, damit es überhaupt so richtig flutsch zu Gast sind? Mario Erdgeist und Luigi Kay, herzlich willkommen beide vom Chaos Computer Club. Guten Abend. Gibt es denn eigentlich einen besonderen Anlass, dass wir das heute machen? Oder ist das einfach nur so, das Internet ist eine Alltagstechnologie, über die vielleicht bisschen mehr Leute Bescheid wissen sollten als nur ihr?
Nein, das Just gerade ist ein Tiefseekabel zwischen Kanada und Europa von einem Anker eines Schiffs getroffen worden und da zeigte sich mal wieder, wie dünn doch die Leitungen sind, die da die Kontinente dort mit dem Paket zusammenhalten. Und das fand man schön an, das Just heute Abend beschlossen, darüber zu reden.
Genau. Dank unserer präkognitiven Fähigkeiten ist dieses Thema schon seit letzter Woche geplant. Sehr gut. Es geht aber also darum, dass wir die normalen Leute, das Internet halt kennen, wir kaufen das bei jemandem. Also wir kennen eigentlich nur zwei Geschäftspartner. Das eine ist sozusagen der ASP, der Inter-Service-Preiter, das heißt der Typ, der dafür sorgt, dass ich zu Hause Internet habe. Die andere Partei, die wir immer kennen, sind die Leute, von denen wir etwas wollen, also der Web-Server quasi. Da ist also irgendwie irgendjemand, der da eine Webseite hingesetzt hat oder irgendeinen anderen Service, den wir anzulaufen können. Manche von uns kennen dann noch eine dritte Partei, die sogenannten Hoster. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mein eigenes Blog betreibe oder so was, eigene Webseite habe, dann verdient er auch wieder irgendjemandem Geld. Jetzt gibt es wahrscheinlich noch ein paar mehr Leute.
Na ich finde dich ja schon sowieso sehr, dass du das so differenzieren kannst. Es gibt Leute, die gehen einfach nicht wirklich ins Internetcafé, sondern wollen einfach Facebook klicken. Also es gibt so ganze Länder, in denen man einfach so seinen Internetcafé einfach nur besucht, wenn Facebook geht. Und wenn nicht, dann geht man da halt nicht hin, sodass du, der du weißt, dass es da Server am anderen Ende gibt, die man da Geld dafür gibt, dass man Zugriff zum Internet hat, ist schon eine ziemliche Transferleistung, die du da anbringst.
Das ist tatsächlich schon zu abstrakt meinst du?
Das ist schon zu abstrakt für viele, ja.
Ja, das hört mich an diesen Witz, wo die Mutter zu ihrem Jungen sagte, bitte verändert doch nicht jeden Tag das Google-Logo, ich komm damit nicht klar. Okay, aber es gibt sozusagen diese, also wenn man sich einen Schritt damit beschäftigt hat, diese großen Parteien, wen gibt es noch? Also was gibt es noch für Player im Internet, die dafür sorgen, dass das so funktioniert, wie es das gerade tut oder vielleicht auch nicht?
Na, also es gibt zum Beispiel, fängt halt vorne an beim kleinen Kunden, zum Beispiel bei jedem zu Hause, fängt halt irgendwie DSL-Leitung an und dann gibt es eigentlich eine unbestimmte Anzahl von Parteien zwischendrin, die den Traffic durchleiten, so dass man dann am Ende Google oder YouTube zum Beispiel drauf hat oder Facebook klicken kann.
Ja, warte, okay, das ist ja eine unbestimmte Anzahl von Parteien, das war ja klar, als wir gesagt haben, wir wollen nur drüber reden.
Na, erstmal die Kabel, die da einfach dich schon mal galvanisch oder dann per Glasfaser von A nach B verbinden, die wurden ja von irgendjemanden in den Fußboden verbuddelt, da wurden Funkstrecken vielleicht aufgesetzt, da wurden vielleicht Untermeereskabel von einem Kontinent zum anderen gespannt mit riesig teuren Schiffen, die dann auch geschützt werden mussten. Da gibt es große Rechenzentren mit Computern, die drinstehen, die nichts weitermachen, als Pakete entgegenzunehmen, in großen Tabellen nachzugucken, wo dann die Empfängeradresse für diese Pakete sind und die das dann weiterleiten. Und dann gibt es noch andere Anbieter, die dir schön verteilt vorgaukeln. Du würdest gerade mit irgendwelchen Servern weit weg sprechen, in Wirklichkeit steht er aber schon vorbereitend bei deinem ISP im Rechenzentrum und stellt da schon mal große Datenmengen, wie nennen wir es höflich, hochauflösende Fortpflanzungsdokumentationen einfach direkt in deiner Nähe zur Verfügung.
Okay, also ihr merkt schon, die die Beteiligten daran sind nicht wenige und wir werden heute versuchen, alle zu besprechen. Allerdings muss man ja wieder sagen, zwei Stunden können noch ganz schön kurz sein. Das heißt, wenn er an irgendeiner Stelle denkt, okay, das würde ich jetzt gerne genauer wissen. Oder, okay, ihr habt jetzt sauber geredet, aber was ist eigentlich damit? Dann ruft ihr an, 0331 70 97 120 0 fragt genauer oder macht das auch, wenn ihr was nicht verstanden habt und gerne noch genauer wissen wollt. Wir haben uns also schon gelernt, nicht jeder Webserver, in dem wir reden, ist tatsächlich dann irgendwie, also nicht jedes Facebook liegt bei Facebook oder jedes YouTube dann direkt dort sozusagen irgendwo in Amerika, sondern irgendwo anders. Da geht es also um Datenverteilung. Was ist denn mit den Kabeln? Also wir haben gerade gehört, irgendwie ein Überseekabel ist irgendwie kaputt gegangen. Sind diese Leute, die die Kontinente verbinden mit diesen Kabeln, sind das einzelne Firmen? Ist das eine Institution? Ist das ein Verein? Wer macht das?
Also bei den Unterseekabeln ist zum Beispiel so, dass Verlegen halt relativ teuer ist, weil das halt ein Kabel, was mehrere tausend Kilometer lang ist. Das kostet halt sehr viel Geld, das zum Beispiel zu verlegen. Dauert auch sehr lange Zeit. Und meistens sind es dann mehrere große Firmen zusammen, die sich dann zusammenschließen und das Kabel zusammen verlegen. Weil zum Beispiel in jedem Kabel stecken in Wirklichkeit mehrere hunderte oder tausende einzelne Kabel drin, die dann wiederum andere Leute nutzen können. Und deswegen zum Beispiel macht das jetzt nicht die Telekom komplett alleine, sondern tut sich dann gleich noch mit drei anderen großen Telekommunikations-Provider in Europa zusammen und legt dann ein großes Kabel zusammen nach Amerika.
Wie ist es bei dem bei dem Hosting? Gibt es da nur eine Ebene? Also sagen, ich miete jetzt bei jemandem einen Web-Server an. Ist das dann genauso diese eine Ebene? Also derjenige kümmert sich darum, dass dann irgendwo ein Rechner steht, der ist auch ans Internet angeschlossen, oder kauft der auch wieder bei irgendjemandem anders ein?
Ja, also ursprünglich, also zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt jemand hingeht und sagt, er will sich einen Blog irgendwo hosten, dann gibt es halt irgendwo einmal die Methode, man klickt sich einen grad auf Tumblr oder auf Blogspot oder irgendwo, meldet sich da an. Dann kann man natürlich auch eine Ebene druntergehen und sagen, ich betreibe meinen eigenen Blog. Dann kauft man sich bei irgendjemand den nackten Web-Space und installiert sich dann selbst einen Wordpress zum Beispiel drauf. Man kann noch eine Ebene druntergehen und sagen, man holt sich einen eigenen Server in einem Rechenzentrum, installiert dann ein eigenes Betriebsthema drauf und das kann man eigentlich so weit runter abstrahieren, bis man dann sagt, man mietet sich die eigenen Kabel, baut sich eigene Häuser und stellt eigene Rechner rein, die dann den Blog ausliefern. Nur das ist dann halt der Fall, wenn man ganz viele Bläser hat.
Ist das, was Fefe gemacht hat? Mit seinem hochverteilten Echtzeit-Java?
Das wollen wir heute nicht so genau wissen. Wie ist es mit den ganzen Sachen, die da noch dazukommen? Es gibt ja die Leute, die dafür sorgen, dass IP-Adressen vergeben werden, dass es URLs überhaupt gibt. Da gibt es dann für jedes Land noch so Behörden. Sind das Leute, die Geld verdienen? Oder sind das gemeinnützige Vereine?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Zum Beispiel in Top-Level-Domains gibt es Organisationen, die die verwalten, zum Beispiel.de verwaltet denig. Das kann man eigentlich von Leuten, die das machen, nur Geld nehmen zur Verwaltung. Manche geben das auch kostenlos raus, wie.tk. Oder es gibt auch welche, die richtig ein Geschäft hintersehen. Zum Beispiel Domains, die mit.tv enden oder so für super viel Geld verkaufen, weil das dann für Firmen, die im Fernsehgeschäft sind, total toll ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab mir neulich eine FM-Domain gegönnt. Wenn ich zu meinem normalen Web-Poster gehe, dann kostet das dreistellig. Und dann bin ich zu einem anderen gegangen, da kostet es ein Drittel. Woher kommt das? Sind die Kosten dafür nicht so groß und die ziehen das einfach nur ab, weil sie können? Oder gibt es tatsächlich für Leute, die in bestimmten Ländern sitzen, sind Domains tatsächlich teurer?
Also technisch gesehen, sowas zu betreiben, ist ein Cent-Betrag, weil man im Endeffekt nur in eine Textdatei irgendwo einträgt, dass jetzt die Domain auf deinem Blog zeigt. Aber je nachdem, wo man jetzt kauft, stecken halt noch verschiedene Firmen mit drin, die dies betreiben, Reseller davon und Reseller von den Resellern. Und dann eine Hoster am Ende. Und so kommen dann halt Beträge. Also für ein DE-Domain zahlt man, glaube ich, ein Zehner im Jahr. Und man kann aber auch sich jetzt eine ganz seltene Domain holen, die ganz weit entfernt liegt, mit unglaublich viel Papierkram, wo man mehrere hundert Euro im Jahr dafür bezahlt.
Na, die Punkt-FM-Domain, die ist ja eigentlich aus Mikronesien. Und es gibt ja Länder, die erlauben einfach Leuten, die nicht Bürgern in diesem Land sind, überhaupt nicht so eine Top-Level-Domain, also eine Domain unter dieser Top-Level-Domain zu betreiben. Sodass dann natürlich der Marktdruck, den du dadurch hast, dass du das nicht einfach mal selber klicken kannst, sondern einen Reseller vielleicht mit einer laxeren Policy auszusuchen, der sich das auch versilbern lässt dann einfach.
Na gut, all das wollen wir heute besprechen. Also die Art und Weise, im Prinzip können wir sagen, wie Geschäfte gemacht werden im Netz und wie das möglicherweise auch sein Netz beeinflusst. Dann würde ich, aber jetzt denken wir fangen am Anfang an. Am Anfang ist die sogenannte letzte Meile. Das ist also sagen, der Punkt von, ihr baut euren Router wahrscheinlich an, der hat ein Kabel und das geht vielleicht noch in einen DSL-Splitter und das geht an ein Kabel, das geht in die Wand. Und was passiert dann?
Also zum Beispiel jetzt, es gibt jetzt verschiedene Arten von letzter Meile. Zum Beispiel gibt es das ganze klassische DSL, das geht über halt zwei Kupferdrähte, meistens von der Telekom. Die wurden, als die Telekom entstanden ist und das mit dem Telefon verbreitet wurde, überall verlegt, jedes Haus hat so einen bekommen. Und die Telekom hat diese Leitung halt verlegt und denen gehören sie noch. Dann gibt es wiederum zum Beispiel noch Kabelmoder im Anbieter, also zumindest zum Beispiel Kabel Deutschland oder Unimedia. Die machen das Ganze nicht über die zwei Kupferdrähte, sondern machen das über Quarks-Kabel, wo eigentlich früher nur das Fernsehen drüber lief. Oder zum Beispiel jetzt jemand, der jetzt ganz neu Kabel zieht, zum Beispiel in Köln war das, glaube ich, der erste Netcolon, die haben da halt Glasfaser in jedes Haus reingelegt und haben damit vor relativ kurzer Zeit noch eigene Kabel verlegt zu den Kunden hin.
Jetzt ist es so, die Telekom hat also diese letzte Meile, wie sind denn da die Geldströme? Also man hört ja oft, ich habe manchmal Telekommunikations-Horror-Blumen, das sind ganz häufig Geschichten, jemand will bei einem anderen Anbieter einen Anschluss machen und dann sagen die, das gehört ja der Telekom. Die Telekom sagt, wir haben aber von einem anderen Anbieter irgendwie nicht diese Dinge bekommen. Wer verdient da wie dran?
Ursprünglich wurden diese Kabel ja von einem Staatsbetrieb verlegt. Das heißt eigentlich waren das Steuergelder, die da reingeflossen sind, um diese Kabel zu verbuddeln. Und man soll sich eigentlich auf die Position stellen, dass die Durchleitung von jedem liebigen Anbieter durch diese jetzt der Telekom gehörenden Kabel, dass die dann zu festgelegten Konditionen dann auch für alle erwerbbar sein sollten. Und da gibt es auch die B-Netz-A, die Bundesnetzagentur hat da auch Regeln aufgestellt, an die sich eigentlich jeder halten muss. Und die ganzen Horrorgeschichten, die man da hört, die liegen daran, dass die Telekom-Mitarbeiter zum Teil noch so ein bisschen Beamtenmentalität haben, aus der Tatsache heraus, dass die damals da auch bei Post noch gearbeitet haben und so sozialisiert wurden.
Das ist aber nicht so sagen, also vielleicht eine böse Unterstellung, wenn man sagt, naja, die wollen einfach ihre Mitanbieter da ein bisschen in Verzug bringen und für einen schlechten Ruf sorgen.
Also es kann auch zum Beispiel daran liegen, weil man zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt ein DSL nicht bei der Telekom kauft, sondern bei irgendjemand anderem, dann mietet dieser DSL-Anbieter trotzdem die letzte Meile bei der Telekom an. Und wenn die dann zum Beispiel im Vertrag stehen haben, dass die letzte Meile ein Jahr gilt, also der Vertrag gilt ein Jahr, dann kann jetzt nicht zwischendrin jemand anders kommen und sagen, aber jetzt biete ich dem Kunden das an, sondern da sind dann halt verschiedene Verträge zwischen den Firmen drin, wem jetzt die letzte Meile, wer darüber was versorgen darf oder wer nicht. Und da kann es dann auch gut mal passieren, dass dann irgendwie gesagt wird, das Kabel ist aber noch belegt bis Ende des Jahres und da können wir jetzt nichts Neues drauf machen.
Wissen Sie, ob man das erfährt als Kunde oder ist es als Kunde dieser Fall, wo man darauf wartet, der Termin verstreicht, der nächste Termin verschreibt, man wird immer einfach immer noch vertröstet.
Ich glaube, als Endkunde merkt man das gar nicht und ein Großteil der Mitarbeiter denkt, wird das auch nicht mitbekommen, bei zum Beispiel der Telekom. Weil es ist einfach so ein riesen Komplex, da arbeiten so viele Leute dran, dass irgendwie, dass dein Kabel zu Hause auch auf den richtigen Port irgendwie, damit der Internet rausfällt, kommt. Und es ist so eine Kette an Prozessen hinten dran, dass man das auch gerne mal irgendwo, glaube ich, auch verlieren kann oder nicht einsieht, wieso da jetzt genau was so ist.
Kann man noch kurz sagen, wie dieses konkrete DSL-Kabel aussieht? Das sind wirklich so zwei kleine Drähte einfach in einer Plastikhülle?
Genau, das sind zwei Kupferkabel, ideal von einer Plastikhülle. Früher waren das, glaube ich, sogar noch Papierhüllen, die inzwischen dann verrottet sind. Also je nachdem, wie alt das ist und was für ein Zustand das ist, sind die Kabel gut bis richtig schlecht.
Ja, aber da haben sie sich dann irgendwann vor ein paar Jahren, als sie DSL erfunden haben, dann noch ein paar Leute mit Grips rangelegt, die so lange daran inginiert haben, bis sie die richtigen Frequenzen bei der Modulation auf diesen Kupferkabeln gefunden haben, wo der geringste Verlust über die Leitung passiert. Das messen sie auch wirklich durch. Die DSL-Leitungen werden dann auch mit unterschiedlichen Frequenzen bespielt, je nachdem, wie lang die noch sind und wie viel Störung du da unterwegs siehst.
Das sind also die ganz normalen DSL-Kabel, Fernseh-Kabel, Coaxial-Kabel, es sind einfach Antennen-Kabel, falls du dieses Wort noch nie gehört hast. Wie sehen die aus? Liegen die dann auch in der Wand, genauso wie sie da aus der Dose kommen?
Die kommen dann genauso aus der Dose, aus der Wand. Der einzige Unterschied ist, der halt gravierend ist, beim DSL-Kabel hast du halt deine eigenen zwei Adern, die bis in den nächsten Verteiler von der Telekom gehen. Also das ist wirklich sozusagen, bei mir beginnen zwei Kabel und die gehen wirklich, also diese beiden Kabel, ohne Unterbrechung mehr oder weniger, die kommen vielleicht nochmal bei einem Kabelverzweiger vorbei, wo ein kleines Kabel zwei verknüpft, aber im Endeffekt hat man dann am Ende zwei Leitungen, die elektrisch durchgeschaltet sind, bis in die Verteilerstationen, die grünigst größere, meistens irgendwie im Hauptpostamt der Stadt, in kleineren Städten und da ist man dann nur alleine drauf. Aber bei dem zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt ein Kabelmodem zu Hause hat, wo dann das Internet übers TV-Kabel kommt, hat man einen gravierenden Unterschied. Und zwar ist man nicht alleine auf diesem Kabel, sondern da hängen dann halt mal irgendwie 100, 500, 1000 Leute auf diesem Kabel mit drauf und nutzen das mit dir.
Okay, das hat dann wahrscheinlich negative Konsequenzen, nehme ich an.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann erzählen, was bei mir zu Hause war. Da hatte mein Vormitbewohner, weil er schwerhörig war, eine Klingel-Extension in sein Zimmer gelegt, so eine Lampe oben ran und jedes Mal, wenn draußen jemand an der Tür geklingelt hat, dann hat er einfach den Netzstrom vom Telefon genommen, um diese Klingel da zu betreiben, sodass bei mir zu Hause immer das Internet plötzlich weg war, wenn draußen jemand gequimmelt hat. Du kannst dir vorstellen, wenn da dann Leute solche lustigen Installationen bei sich zu Hause am Start haben, dass dann bestimmt auch der gesamte Hausflur darunter leidet. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich ja einzig gewesen bin, der da bei diesen schlecht galvanisch getrennten Kabeln dann nicht drunter gelitten hat.
Wie ist es denn beim Fiberglas, was ja irgendwie noch neu ist, mehr oder weniger, oder nicht so weit verbreitet, wie läuft das da?
Na ursprünglich gab es ja dieses unsägliche Opal. Da hatte die Telekom irgendwann mal angefangen, wegen, man müsste den Osten ja jetzt mal mit richtigem Internet versorgen, so Glasfaserkabel zu verlegen, dieses ganze Projekt hieß Opal. Und hatte dann diese unschöne Eigenschaft, dass sie dazu von Alcatel, glaube ich, sich da so Brückenkopfstationen holen mussten, die dann ihnen zu teuer waren.
Was sind Brückenkopfstationen?
Das ist so die Stelle, wo du anschließt das Glasfaserkabel und von der anderen Seite dann wieder Kupfer rauskommt, damit dein Telefon zu Hause, damit du auch telefonieren kannst. Und dann war denen das für pro Haus zu teuer, nein, nicht pro Wohnung zu teuer, sodass sie den ganzen Hause da einfach nur mit angeschlossen haben. Was dann auch wieder dazu führte, dass man eigentlich genug Bandbreite unten im Haus anliegen hatte, um sich dort Glasfaser hinzulegen. Aber das am Ende dann für die DSL-Leitung im Haus einfach nicht mehr ausgereicht hat. Sodass du dann wirklich warten musstest, bis derjenige in deinem Haus ausgezogen ist, der DSL hatte. Damit du dann die freigeworrene DSL-Leitung bekommst. Geile Anzeichen.
Das übliche Schema da ist auch, weil man halt irgendwie die Glasfaser zwar einfach in den Keller bekommt, da macht man irgendwie eine Bohrung, schiebt das Kabel durch. Aber um die Glasfaser dann in die Wohnung zu bekommen, müsste man ja rein theoretisch das Treppenhaus zum Beispiel aufreißen. Deswegen ist da eigentlich gängige Praxis, dass man eine Glasfaser bis in den Keller legt. Und dort kommt dann eigentlich das, wo die Kupferdoppelader beim DSL endet. Statt irgendwie auf einem großen Kasten, wo dann irgendwie 500 Leute drauf hängen, hat man jetzt den kleinen da, wo irgendwie 10 Leute drauf hängen. Und dann im Haus selbst hat man dann wieder DSL. Und da kriegst du halt auf die Kürze sehr viel höhere Übertragungsraten hin, über vier Kilometer oder so.
Und das macht Netcolon, also was ihr jetzt als Beispiel ange-
Genau, die haben dann einen sogenannten Mini-D-Slam im Keller verbaut, wo dann halt die Kupferkabel dran sind. Und oben kann dann jeder mit seinem DSL-Modem wieder ganz normal drüber surfen.
Dann gibt es ja sowas, also wir lernen irgendwie, es gibt jetzt drei verschiedene Arten, per Kabel Internet zu bekommen. Und das landet dann mehr oder weniger immer an einem Verteiler. Jetzt gibt es auch mittlerweile Leute, die haben einfach einen weißen Kasten, bei sich zuhause stehen, oder vielleicht auch einen schwarzen, da steht dann eine SIM-Karte drin. Die haben sozusagen UMTS. Wie läuft das? Ist das einfach nur ganz normal über das Handynetz? Oder gibt es da besondere Anbieter oder Anbindungen?
Das ist einfach, in bestimmten Regionen, wo sich Fuchs und Hase noch gute Nacht sagen, die Hörer hier in Brandenburg werden das kennen, da ist einfach zu anstrengend, zu teuer, einzelne Häuser einfach mit einer Kupferkabel zu verbinden. Weil da musst du ja mit einem Bagger dahergehen und den aufbuddeln. Und naja, dann sagt die Telekom, aber du hast da dann ein Kabel liegen, das ist aber zu weit weg vom nächsten DSLAM, also vom nächsten DSL-Konzentrator.
Also der, der dein Signal von zu Hause aufgreift und verstärkt, ich sage mal, große Netz einspeist?
So ungefähr. Und du bist einfach zu weit entfernt. Und hier ISDN ist doch eigentlich gut genug und schönen Tag noch. Und wenn du dann aber trotzdem gerne Internet auch schnell hättest, um dann deine Fortpflanzungsdokumentation runterladen zu können, hochauflösend, dann bleibt dir am Ende ja nichts weiter übrig, als dir das Internet aus der Luft kommen zu lassen. Und da gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Möglichkeit ist wirklich, das Mobilfunknetz zu benutzen dafür. Und die andere Möglichkeit ist, weiter ISDN als Hinkanal zu benutzen, um Anfragen zu stellen und dir sämtliche Daten dann über den Satelliten auf eine kleine Satellitenschüssel in deinem Zuhause runterbrezeln zu lassen. Was aber immer den lustigen Effekt hat, dass alle den Nachbarn auch immer gucken können, was da für Pakete dann noch...
Ist das tatsächlich unverschlüsselt?
Das ist erstmal noch unverschlüsselt, ja.
Also wie macht man das? Man setzt einfach eine Schüssel auf und richtet die aus und dann guckt man, was der Nachbar, oder wie?
Der Satelliter streut halt einmal so grob in die Richtung, weil er halt nicht irgendwie genau dein Haus mit zwei Meter Genauigkeit treffen kann. Und deswegen streut er dann halt mal über so ganz Deutschland oder ganz Europa einfach dein Traffic. Und wenn er halt nicht verschlüsselt ist, dann kann ihn jeder sozusagen empfangen.
Jetzt ist es ja bei den Sachen, die wir schon gesehen haben. Also die Kabeldinger, das sind halt die Anbieter sozusagen, die die da vor allen Dingen mit dem Geld zu tun haben. Jetzt die Telekom immer noch, wenn es um die ganz normale Telefonhaltung geht. Wie beim OMTS ist es halt so, dann ist er einfach der Mobilfunkanbieter. Wie ist es beim Satelliten? Gibt es dann auch einfach nur ein Anbieter, der sich darauf spezialisiert? Oder bezahlt man dann mit einem Schlag gleich mehrere Firmen?
Ja, da gibt es halt einen Reseller, der dann einfach dir anbietet, für dich da erstmal erst eine Gegenstelle zu spielen und dann die Pakete dort dann als Antwort anders routet und dir die über den Satelliten zur Verfügung stellt. Der kauft natürlich auch dann Kapazität bei den Satellitenbetreibern ein. Der wird dann nicht selber jetzt die Ariane buchen und die Dinge in den Orbit schießen, aber ja.
Ist das alles, was wir bis jetzt gebraucht haben, noch eine einfache finanzielle Transaktion? Also, ich gebe einem Typen Geld, damit der mir Internet gibt? Oder gibt es dann im Hintergrund laufen da schon andere Sachen ab?
Ja, also, du siehst halt echt nur, dass du deine 1999 an irgendwie deinen Mobilfunkprovider oder deinen DSL Provider gibst. Aber im Hintergrund wird dann zum Beispiel deine Anbindung bezahlt. Also deine zwei Kupferadern, die in dein Haus gehen, werden, also die Telekom stellt dann halt die Rechnung an jemand anderes weiter. Also da sind dann mehrere Parteien mit enthalten. Und zum Beispiel, wenn der Traffic dann auch bei der Telekom angekommen ist, muss er ja auch irgendwo hinkommen, was dann auch nochmal Geld kostet. Also da spielen diverse Parteien mit bei der Sache und ja.
Na ja, eigentlich würde im Prinzip, könnte es ja schon, wenn du nur bestimmte Protokolle im Internet benutzen wolltest, würde es schon fast reichen. Wenn du so bei der Telekom bist und jetzt einfach nur beim Telekom Rechenzentrum, sieh dich da wieder untereinander routen. Dann kannst du schon mal anfangen auch so per Peer to Peer deine hochauflösenden Dokumentationen zu verteilen.
Okay, es gibt bei dem Anschluss, also bei dem Anschluss zu Hause noch die eine spannende Frage, die viele von uns sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr stellen, weil es einfach schon so gelernt und gewohnt ist. Und das ist nämlich die Frage, warum der Download immer viel, viel größer ist als der Upload. Also runter geht es wirklich ganz groß und oben ist es eher so Tröpfel, Tröpfel, Tröpfel, wenn ich irgendwas hochladen will. Wir sprechen darüber nach den Nachrichten. Bevor wir die Nachrichten machen, würde ich kurz noch Sven dran nehmen. Der hat nämlich eine Frage, die ich schon selber nicht ganz verstehe. Er sagt nämlich, ob man tote Knotenpunkte im Netz nutzen kann, um schneller unterwegs zu sein. Sven, hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Was genau meinst du damit?
Na ja, wenn man sich, egal, ich hab das jetzt verfolgt, das heißt irgendwie anders, hab ich gerade mitgekriegt, wenn ich aus meinem Haus rausgehe, in so eine Art Verbindung, um dann in die große, dicke Leitung zu kommen. Kommt ja immer drauf an, wie weit dieser Knotenpunkt oder dieser Verbinder halt entfernt ist. Dementsprechend länger brauch ich natürlich, um ihn überhaupt zu verbinden. Und da hab ich mal gehört, man kann dem Router bestimmen, mit welchem, ja wie sagt man, welchen Eingang er nehmen soll, um halt den Weg zu kürzen, damit er schneller reingeht.
Versteht ihr, was Stefan sagt?
Na so ungefähr.
Okay, erklär mal bitte.
Also was ich mir vorstelle, ist, du musst dir vorstellen, dass bei dir zu Hause wirklich zwei Kupferkabel bei dir physikalisch ankommen, aber das sind nicht die einzigen. Es kann sein, dass das, was bei dir im Haus nach oben gelegt wird, jetzt ein schlechtes Kabel ist. Also kannst du dir ein Kabelpaar deiner Nachbarn suchen, also vielleicht deiner Ex-Nachbarn am besten, sonst werden die Nachbarn sauer. Und schließt das da an und guckst, ob dort vielleicht die Qualität des Kabels besser ist. Das ist so üblicherweise, wo sie dir einen Techniker vorbeischicken, der dann schaut, ob vielleicht irgendein anderes Kabelpaar besser ist.
Nee, nee, das meine ich nicht. Ich meine, wenn ich eine Suchanfrage im Internet oder im Kippse, und dann gibt es ja diese Millisekunden, die da runterlaufen, wie lange die Suchanfrage bearbeitet ist und wie lange das dauert. Und manchmal ist halt vorprogrammiert, dass der halt mit dem und dem Server erst mal verbindet, um dann da eine Frage zu stellen. Und ich hab mal einen Kollegen gehabt, der hat da eine bestimmte Adresse eingeben, wo er eher drüber laufen soll, weil da so weniger Leute anfangen und dadurch die Frage schneller beantwortet wird.
Ja, das ist jetzt so schon ein bisschen, wollen wir später noch zu erzählen. Aber du kannst halt bei so einem klassischen Content Provider, der halt an ganz vielen Rechenzentren in der Welt vertreten ist, da gibst du dann halt zum Beispiel google.com ein und du landest bei dem Google Rechenzentrum in Berlin oder in Frankfurt. Aber wenn du kannst, wenn du halt zum Beispiel die genaue IP-Adresse weißt, kannst du auch das in Paris ansprechen. Auch wenn das jetzt ganz weit weg liegt und viel langsamer, viel länger dauert dazu zu kommunizieren.
Ja, wir haben damals extra so einen alten Telekommensache da eine geben, weil die nimmt keiner mehr, weil die eigentlich, wie man sagt, tot ist oder selten angesprochen wird und dadurch ist da einfach mehr Platz und das geht schneller. Und wie hat er mir das so erklärt? Ich bin ja nur okay ein Prof, ne? In so Sachen.
Ja, das kann man jetzt auch so ähnlich sehen, dass man halt, also ich weiß nicht, ob das richtig geht, aber früher beim Dial-in, also wenn du halt mit deinem 56k Modem noch eine Telefonnummer eingeben hast, eine Benutzernamen und Passwort, dann verbindest du dich ja auf irgendwie eine Gegenstelle, wo dann das Internet wieder ist. Und da kann man dann ja rein theoretisch alte ungenutzte Knoten sozusagen, die es noch gibt, nutzen. Aber bei DSL, glaube ich, geht das inzwischen gar nicht mehr so, weil da ist ja irgendwie alles genau gebunden und du kommst auch wenn du deinen Benutzernamen eingibst, immer auf dem nächsten Server, an der bei dir steht. Also ich glaube, dass was du meinst, ist inzwischen alles so weit optimiert, dass das immer schnell läuft.
Ist natürlich traurig, weil ich hab hier angeblich 6000 und kriege gerade mal 128, wenn überhaupt. Ja, also das ist Schlaf, Schlaf, Schlaf, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Ich bin ja auch in NRW zwischen Meere und Bergen. Also da fällt auch UMTS flach, ja. Ja, und es gibt keine Alternative hier halt.
Aber ich würde sagen, das was dir erzählt worden ist, das wird auch eher Voodoo sein, als tatsächlich was wirklich was bringen. Ich wünsche trotz der 128, du hast viel Glück noch. Wir machen jetzt hier erstmal das Fritz Info mit Nachricht, Weiter und Verkehr und danach klären wir mal, warum wir viele tausend Gigabyte Download-Kapazität haben, aber nur ganz, ganz wenige Kilobyte Upload.
Hallo, ich bin Marion, die schwebende Jungfrau. Aufgepasst.
Marion, also wenn du so jungfäulich bist, wie du schwebst, dann... Au! Ist doch nicht so schlimm. Üb doch einfach noch ein bisschen. Also das Schweben. Auf der Bühne die unentdeckten Talente. Also hier außerdem die Gewinner der letzten Nacht der Talente. Ein geiler Überraschungsact und ein Radio, das den ganzen Abend in die ganze Welt überträgt. Samstag, 13. Oktober im Großen Saal vom Admiralspalast Berlin.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten auch bei Fritz im Netz. Die Fritz Nacht der Talente.
Moderiert von den Radio-Fritzen Katrin Thüring und Chris Guse.
Um kurz nach halb 11.
Die seit Tagen angekündigten Streiks der Lufthansa Flugbegleiter sollen morgen starten. Die genaue Uhrzeit der Streiks und die betroffenen Flughäfen will die Gewerkschaft UFO aber erst 6 Stunden vorher bekannt geben. Voraussichtlich werden die Flughäfen in Berlin, Frankfurt und München betroffen sein. Lufthansa kündigte an, man wolle die Auswirkungen so gering wie möglich halten. In Oranienburg ist auch die 2. Bombe beseitigt worden. Der Sperrkreis um den Bahnhof wurde wieder aufgelöst. Ob durch die Sprengungen etwas beschädigt wurde, konnte die Stadt noch nicht sagen. Am Nachmittag war eine weitere Bombe im Süden der Stadt beseitigt worden. Die Arbeiten hatten sich unter anderem wegen technischer Probleme verzögert. Das Drama Barbara geht als deutscher Beitrag in den Wettbewerb um den Oscar 2013. Es geht um den Preis für den besten nicht englischsprachigen Film. Eine Fachjury in München hat sich für das Drama über eine ostdeutsche Ärztin entschieden. Schon bei der Berlinale 2012 bekam der Film von Regisseur Christian Petzold den silbernen Beeren für die beste Regie. Der Iran hat nach Angaben der Internationalen Atomenergieorganisation eine seiner Urananreicherungsanlagen beträchtlich erweitert. Die Zahl der Zentrifugen in dem unterirdischen Komplex sei seit Mai auf 2000 verdoppelt worden, heißt es in dem neuesten Bericht der Behörde. Der Westen wirft Teheran vor, nach Atomwaffen zu streben. Die iranische Regierung weist dies zurück und pocht auf ihr Recht zur friedlichen Nutzung der Atomenergie.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin haben wir um die 19 Grad und auch in Brandenburg-Stocken momentan hängen die Temperaturen momentan bei 18, 19 Grad fest. In der Nacht müsst ihr mit Regen rechnen und es geht noch runter bis auf 12 Grad. Morgen wird es dann eher nicht so prall, es wird grau und regnerisch und maximal 18 Grad werden wir erreichen. Zum Wochenende wird es dann aber wieder etwas freundlicher. Die Straßen sind frei, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Auf fritz.de slash mitmachen.
Das war so nicht geplant und wird jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen zu lange dauern. Heute das Chaos Radio mit Erdgeist und Kay vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir erklären euch heute das Internet. Allerdings nicht wie die kleinen Datenpakete von einem Ort zum anderen kommen, sondern wer daran alles beteiligt ist und die Infrastruktur aufbaut. Wir sind gerade bei der letzten Meile, also dem Stück Internet, was dann wirklich vom ersten größeren Verteilerkasten zu euch nach Hause geht, wollen gleich noch klären, warum die Downloadgeschwindigkeit sich von der Uploadgeschwindigkeit so krass unterscheidet, wollen vorher aber noch einen kleinen Blick in die sonstige Hackerwelt werfen. Herr Erdgeist, die hatten da was vorbereitet, was es noch so einen kleineren, interessanteren News Bites gibt in den letzten Wochen?
Ah, ein bisschen was vorbereitet. Ich wollte die Campus Party runnen, die uns hier in Berlin...
Wie lohnt das denn?
Na, wir vom CCC veranstalten ja auch so alle vier Jahre hier in Berlin oder respektive in der Nähe von Berlin eine Hackerveranstaltung. Und dieses Jahr wurden wir überrascht von einer Veranstaltung, die Campus Party, und die fand so in der letzten Woche statt. Und einige interessierte Hacker haben sich das angeguckt, respektive angucken wollen, und sind dann da schon beim Einlass so ein bisschen harsh behandelt worden. Aber Markus, ich hab gehört, du bist da auch vorbeigegangen.
Ja, also der Einlass bei der Campus Party war sehr lustig, weil das ist ja ein altes Flughafengelände. Und das war ein Tempelhof, und wenn man da reinkommt, das ist schon sehr eindrucksvoll. Man sieht ja diese riesige Flughafenhalle und denkt so, wow, krass. Und das war relativ leer an dem ersten Tag noch. Das Einzige, was irgendwie wie so, das haben die vergessen, als sie den Flughafen zugemacht haben, die Sicherheitsschleusen waren noch da. Tatsächlich sozusagen so Einlässe aufgebaut mit so Tischen, wo man auch seine Taschen durchgucken lassen musste. Da wurde nämlich geguckt nach Alkohol. Da wurde auch tatsächlich zu sagen, da hab ich Geschichte gehört, zumindest Trinkflaschen aufgeschraubt und dran gerochen. Und man musste ein Foto von sich machen lassen, das ich jetzt mal mit böser Zunge biometrietauglich nenne.
Das war auch gefordert, extra das zu geben.
Ja, nee, du durftest schon irgendwie so lächeln und so. Das war nicht ganz so fies wie unser Personalausweis, aber das war schon so, dass man dachte, aha, interessant. Und dann, das Schönste war dann, als ich raus wollte, da haben sie mich nicht rausgelassen, weil ich einen Notebook im Rucksack hatte. Da dachte ich so, aha, die hat das nicht registriert. Aha, das heißt, ich soll jetzt raus, ich darf nicht raus, weil ich einen Notebook im Rucksack hatte. Ja, ich muss aber dringend raus. Du kannst ja einfach durchrennen und dann hauen wir dir in die Fresse. Na gut, dann bin ich zurückgegangen und dann kriegt man so einen Aufkleber drauf, was totaler Quatsch ist natürlich, weil ich irgendeinen Notebook hätte abgeben können. Ja, und dann durfte ich wieder raus. Und dann innen drin waren auch sozusagen mehr Sicherheitsbeamte als Besucher, zumindest am ersten Tag, das war schon alles so sehr straff organisiert und nicht so geil. Also ich fand's schon auch bezeichnend, dass man in einer Community, die ja dafür bekannt ist, dass sie so gerne auf Anonymität und Freiheit wertigt, die Seriennummern in den Rechnern aufschreibt, weiß ich nicht so genau.
Ja, da ich hatte dort die sehr bezeichnenden Fotos von den riesigen Reihen von blauen O2-Zelten gesehen, die dort in Reihe und Glied aufgestellt waren und hatte das dann so mir vom inneren Auge als Kontrast zu den Luftbildern, die es vom Camp regelmäßig gibt, mit denen doch eher organisch gewachsenen Zeltreihen verglichen und wusste eigentlich, auf welche Veranstaltung ich lieber möchte.
Ja, also bei dem Sponsoring, das war so das, was ich so am wenigsten schlimm fand, weil ich dachte so, okay, kann man auch so machen. Ist nicht so schön und sagen, vom Geschmack her ist es nicht so geil, aber meine Güte. Aber der Rest der Partien, naja gut, wenn ihr auch was zu sagen habt, könnt ihr gerne noch irgendwie ein bisschen ein Chat rumraten zur Sendung. Chaosradio.de. Ach so, apropos Chaosradio.de. Es gibt ja da so eine Website zu dieser Sendung, die war ja dann auf einmal weg. Was ich mir auf Twitter anhören musste ist, ha ha, der Typ, der im Radio immer sagt, man soll schön Backups machen und jetzt ist Chaosradio.de down. Was bitte war da los, meine Herren?
Ja, da hat eine Festplatte ein bisschen Schluck auf gehabt und geklemmt. Und nachdem jemand vorbeigegangen ist und dem Rechner ein paar Streichel enthalten gegeben hat, läuft es jetzt wieder. Und es gibt Backups.
Und das hat zwei Wochen gedauert?
Der steht heute in Amsterdam und weißt du, die Amsterdamer sind ja auch nicht dafür bekannt, dass die jetzt da...
Die haben die über ihre hochauflösenden Fortplanungsdokumentationen geguckt?
Ja, die gibt's ja.
Ah gut, also Server steht jetzt wieder und es sind wahrscheinlich keine Vorkehrungsmaßnahmen getroffen worden, dass das noch mal passieren könnte.
Ja, wir überlegen gerade, was wir weiter mit dem Server machen, ob man vielleicht hierher umzieht, dass man einfach ran kann oder...
Vielleicht einen CDN draus machen. Da erzählen wir später noch.
Gut. So, dann geht's zurück zum Thema, wo wir gerade noch letztes Bit zu dem Hausanschluss... Es ist ja so, also wie gesagt, bei mir zu Hause ist es, ich habe, glaube ich, 32 MBit Download und... Oh, lass mich lügen, zwei oder ein MBit Upload. Und das sind ja schon Größen.
Aber auch real hast du das mal...
Natürlich nicht.
Ach so, schuldige.
Entschuldige mal bitte, auf dem Papier. Aber was auch real ist, ist, ich habe die Downloadgeschwindigkeit viel höher als die Uploadgeschwindigkeit. Warum ist das so?
Genau, bei Cable ist das relativ einfach zu erklären. Da hat man es halt beim Downstream, spricht halt eine sogenannte CMTS, also einmal der Router und schickt Daten raus. Aber wenn dann Daten zurückkommen, sprechen halt mehrere hundert oder tausend Leute gleichzeitig auf dem Kabel. Und dadurch ist es halt sehr schwer, da so viele Leute unterzubringen. Und da bleibt dann einfach für den Upstream weniger übrig als für den Downstream. Weil den Downstream kann man halt viel besser managen, weil es halt nur eine Stelle ist. Wenn das jetzt bei der Glasfaser so ist, gibt es nicht wirklich technische Limitierungen, weil über den Glasfaser kann man auch diverse Male 10 Gigabit drüber machen ohne Probleme. Da ist das mehr so ein politisches Ding dann zu sagen, ja, ihr habt nur 100 MBit up und 1 Gigabit down oder 10 und 100.
Politisch heißt Geld.
Ja, da ist dann irgendwie das Marketing, das sagt halt, wir wollen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie 100 hoch und 100 runter anbieten, sondern nur 10 hoch.
Die Leute haben sich doch über die Jahre daran gewöhnt, dass es so ist. Und wenn man richtig schönes, schnelles, symmetrisches Internet haben möchte, dann muss man sich eine Standleitung besorgen. Und so eine Standleitung wird dann einfach für dich extra verbuddelt. Das hat super funktioniert, so dass Firmen, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie wirklich ein symmetrisches Netz zu Hause haben, die haben da auch unglaubliche Mengen Geld dafür gelatzt. Und wenn das einfach funktioniert, dann muss man die Leute jetzt nicht mit so Dingen verwirren, dass es plötzlich auch mit dem Endkunden-Internet genauso gut funktionieren könnte. Die Endkunde will das ja üblicherweise auch nicht. Entschuldige mal bitte. Was hat denn der Endkunde groß hochzuladen? Der hat gefälligste Fernsehen zu konsumieren, am besten vom DSL-Anbieter selber.
Oder Dokumentationen in hoher Auflösung.
Oder fortpflanzende Dokumentationen herunterzuladen. Er konsumiert halt lieber, als dass er was anbietet.
Das ist schon gut, aber ich möchte trotzdem fragen. Natürlich kann man sagen, wenn ich meinen Podcast hochlade, merke ich schon deutlich, wenn ich an der dicken Leitung sitze, dann geht das ein paar Sekunden. Wenn ich zu Hause sitze, dann geht das in einer Minute oder zwei. Das sind halt 40 Megabyte. Da kann man sagen, du lädst dreimal einen Podcast in der Woche hoch, das ist nicht so schlimm, kann man warten. Aber hätte das nicht schon eine positive Auswirkung, wie z.B. sowas wie Videotelefonie?
Ja, das braucht ja eigentlich schon. Videotelefonie kann man ja dann so runter komprimieren, z.B. Skype macht das ja so. Die komprimieren das dann so, dass wenig Bandbreite braucht. Und dann geht das auch ohne Probleme über deine DSL-Leitung noch. Nein.
Na, du kannst die aber auch. Es gibt Anbieter, die dir einfach QoS, also Quality of Service, für bestimmte Paketarten anbieten. Die gucken in deine Pakete rein und sagen, das sieht wie Videotelefonie aus. Und die wird dann halt bevorzugt transportiert.
Entschuldige, ich möchte nicht, dass Anbieter in meine Pakete reingucken.
Ich stelle ja nur fest, ich habe es nicht beworben.
Die Frage ist wirklich, wenn wir alle symmetrisches Internet hätten, also Downloads so groß wie Upload oder umgedreht, würde man das sozusagen merken? Also hätte das positive Effekte für uns im normalen Gebrauch?
Na, ich denke schon. Ich habe aber auch so ein bisschen diese humanistische Bildung und den Glauben, dass alle Menschen dort irgendwie Sender und Empfänger im Internet gleichzeitig sein sollten und jeder was Spannendes auch im Internet beizutragen hat. Da gibt es Leute, die einfach anderes Menschenbild haben und scheinen sich ganz gut zu verkaufen.
Und ich glaube, ein Großteil der Leute wird das überhaupt nicht wirklich merken, weil sie nichts hochladen, außer ihre zehn Fotos auf Facebook. Und nicht einen Podcast oder ein Video mehrmals am Tag.
So, jetzt haben wir Patrick in der Leitung. Der muss jetzt dazu sagen, hallo Patrick.
Hi, grüß euch.
Wir möchten heute eigentlich gerne über die theoretischen Hintergründe der Ökonomie des Internets reden. Das heißt, stell mal deine Frage und wir werden gucken, ob sich das ja irgendwie einbauen lässt, aber wir wollen heute quasi keine Beratungs-Sendung machen.
Ich hab aber erst später eingeschaltet, und sorry, wenn ich jetzt völlig daneben liege. Ich wohne am Ende der Welt, Seelo, polnische Grenze. Ich hab mich total gefreut, als es überhaupt mal Satelliteninternet gab. Hab das eifrig genutzt. Ich bin dann umgestiegen auf LTE. Als es das auf einmal gab, war ich nicht zufrieden. Und jetzt hat die Telekom mir auf einmal eine 16.000er Leitung zur Verfügung gestellt. Über die alte Telefonleitung. Da ist aber folgendes Problem. Das ist Telefonie über Voice-over-IP. Und diese Telefonie bricht regelmäßig, also man kann da die Uhr nachstellen, nach zwei Tagen ab. Es ist nicht mehr möglich, mich anzurufen. Ich kann nicht mehr rausgehen. Ich müsste alles resetten. Auch das klappt nicht wirklich. Der Witz ist, und das ist meine Frage, das Einzige, was ich anrufen kann, über dieses Telefon ist die Telekom-Hotline. Und dann? Das kann ich also wirklich verbindlich alle zwei Tage protokollieren. Das ist jetzt kein Scherz von mir. Und die Leute wissen selber, die sind ja tatsächlich, muss man denen lassen, Kunden-Service einklingeln, die sind dran. Mich haben da zig Nerds zurückgerufen. Ein bisschen kenne ich mich mit der Materie aus, aber das verstehe ich nicht.
Du kannst die Nummer dann erreichen, was passiert dann?
Nein, da kommt Verbindungsaufbau nicht möglich.
Aber du sagst ja alle zwei Tage, wie kommt es denn dazu, dass dein Telefon wieder funktioniert?
Da muss ich dann anrufen.
Und was machen die dann?
Die sagen, die machen gar nichts. Aber es geht mir eine halbe Stunde später wieder.
Was?
Das hört sich aber esoterisch an.
Aber jetzt mal hier die Herren, gibt es da für eine technische Erklärung?
Das könnte mit den Sonnenstürmen zusammenhängen.
Oder dem Uhrzeitknall, der sich da noch auswirkt. Ja, so komme ich mir nämlich auch vor.
Ich finde, du sprichst da schon einen spannenden Punkt an. Als ich in Südamerika vorbeigekommen bin, habe ich irgendwann mal gemerkt, dass all meine Gespräche von meinem echt extrem low-cost Billig-Anbieter, die quer durch die Welt gingen, so verdammt billig gewesen sind. Und auf der anderen Seite aber immer eine komische Nummer aus London rauskam. Und stellte sich dann irgendwann raus, dass dieser Billig-Anbieter einfach Skype benutzt hat und Skype Dial-Out dann auf mein Mobiltelefon draufgelegt hat und ich dann mit Europa mein Mobiltelefon über Skype und den Dial-Out gelegt hab.
Wir reden von der Telekom.
Ich glaube, die werden nicht Skype benutzen, aber ist das natürlich der Trend, geht dahin, statt irgendeine ESDN-Leitung, die ja eine definierte Qualität haben muss zu jeder Zeit, einfach Paketbasiertes telefonieren zu verkaufen, kann man natürlich dann einfach dynamischer mit planen. Und das ist schon vielleicht nicht, weiß nicht, von der Telekom vielleicht schon auch ein Schachzug über die letzte Zeit.
Aber diese Regelmäßigkeit erklärt das nicht, oder?
Das ist halt Software, Herr Yi. Das sind halt Programme von Leuten geschrieben.
Okay, also das ist aber dann eher sozusagen nichts, was mit dem Aufbau des Internets zu tun hat, sondern wird eher in der Voice-over-IP-Software.
Also Internet läuft parallel 1A.
Ja, oder vielleicht ist dann in der...
Also wirklich, da kann ich nicht meckern. Ich hab hier von den zugesicherten 16.000 Download und auch im Upload komme ich immer nahe dran.
Mein Neid ist bei dir.
Das dürfte ich mich nicht beschweren, weil ich verstehe die technischen Hintergründe nicht.
Also Patrick, wir können ja leider auch nicht helfen.
Du kannst einfach Zipgate oder sowas benutzen, wenn das Internet tut. Dann kannst du ja Telefon von woanders beziehen. Das stimmt.
Ich find ja nicht doof, mach ich auch.
Dann ist ja gut. Patrick, dann noch viel Spaß beim Telefonieren. So, es sind wirklich seltsame Probleme, die da auch auftauchen. Immer wieder in diesem seltsamen Internet, von denen die Leute mal reden. Ich würde jetzt gerne zu diesen CDNs was hören. Ist AKMAY ein CDN? Gut, dann würde ich jetzt gerne... Das ist nämlich ein Punkt, den ich selber...
Guck doch auf unsere Choreografie, wir sind da noch weit.
Es ist schon 22.48 Uhr, verstehst du?
Wir haben doch auch bis Mitternacht.
Alles klar, dann bitte.
Wir wollten jetzt eigentlich mal gucken, was dann passiert, nachdem das Paket durch deine Wand durch, auf der anderen Seite angekommen ist, die Telekom hat jetzt so ein Paket und sieht, das soll nach Google oder zu einem Battle-Netz-Server, von wo du World of Warcraft spielst oder so.
Mach ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Machst du schon lange nicht mehr? Du bist erwachsen geworden. Level 80 und einfach aufgegeben.
Ich war noch nie maximal Level. Jetzt bleib beim Thema, Erdgeist.
Schuldige. Da hast du jetzt Pakete und in diesen Paketen steht drin, wo sie herkommen, wo sie hin sollen. Und es gibt so jetzt den dringenden Bedarf dafür zu sorgen, dass so ein Paket dann auch wirklich einen Weg findet. Und da haben sich so Firmen, die DSL verkaufen an Kunden und Firmen, die so Kabel verbuddelt haben zwischen den Kontinenten, haben jetzt da das dringende Bedürfnis, sich da irgendwie zu verknoten und dafür zu sorgen, dass so ein Paket dann auch wirklich dort ausgetauscht wird und dort den richtigen Pfad nimmt, um dort hinzukommen, wo es am Ende hin soll. Und diese Knotenpunkte, die heißen Internet-Exchange. Und das sind meistens Vereine, von denen viele Firmen Mitglieder sind, die ein Interesse daran haben, diese Pakete auszutauschen. Und die mieten sich dann so satzungsgemäß irgendwo Häuser an, müssen da Strom bezahlen, müssen da Klima bezahlen, müssen dafür sorgen, dass möglichst aus allen vier Himmelsrichtungen da Kabel ankommen, sodass nicht ein Bagger oder irgendjemand mit Spaten auf der Suche nach Kupfer das Ding ausbuddelt und dann das ganze Rechenzentrum dort dann netzlos schaltet. Und an diesen Internet-Exchange-Punkten da stellen die dann alle so Computer rein. Und diese Computer machen wirklich nichts weiter als in ganz großen Tabellen nachgucken, wo dann so ein reinkommendes Paket als nächstes weitervermittelt werden muss.
In welcher Größenordnung sind diese Teile denn verteilt? Also gibt es irgendwie eins in Europa, eins in jedem Land, eins in jeder Stadt?
Also es gibt halt einmal so die großen in Europa. Die stehen dann in London, Amsterdam und Frankfurt, weil das sind halt so die Internet-Hauptstädte. Da sind halt sehr viele Provider anwesend und die verbinden sich dann darüber. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch kleine regionale Peering-Punkte. Die sind dann ja in München, Düsseldorf, Hamburg, jeder größeren Stadt, die eins, zwei Rechenzentren hat.
Berlin? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, so ein Haus eigentlich? Ist das sozusagen so eine bewachte, mit Stacheldraht umzäunte Zentrale, wo Panzerdome rumfahren oder?
Ja, da gibt es so verschiedenste Ebenen. Also es gibt irgendwie so in Polen gibt es zum Beispiel ein so ein großes Hotel, wo auch zufällig ganz viele Glasfaserkabel ankommen. Und da gibt es oben unterm Dachboden einen großen Raum. Und da stehen Racks und da hausen auch die Tauben. Und da werden halt die Kabel zusammengesteckt. Das ist jetzt so der richtige Extremfall. Es gibt natürlich auch das Gesamt andere. Es gibt Rechenzentri, die können irgendwie tagelang unabhängig laufen, haben Stacheldrahtzäune und Überwachung. Und da darfst du nur rein, wenn du deinen Fingerabdruck und dein Personalausweis abgibst. Also da gibt es verschiedenste Sicherheitsstufen und Qualitätsklassen, die von irgendwie schwarz bis weiß gehen.
Aber wenn man sich das anguckt, dann muss man sich dort wieder vor Augen führen, dass das schon Infrastruktur ist, die regelmäßig betrieben werden muss, die dann auch ernsthaft Kosten verursacht, die sich ja am Ende dann irgendwo wieder niederschlagen müssen. Also du hast ja Kosten beim Verbuddeln der letzten Meile, beim natürlich nach Hause liefern von so Routern, wie Kunden Service haben, wie die ganzen DSL Provider haben, da schon Kosten. Und jetzt kommen weitere Kosten hinzu, nämlich dort an diesen Internet Exchange-Punkten, wo wirklich Häuser betrieben, wo Strom hingelegt werden muss, wo Abwärme hingelegt werden muss, wo man für Redundanz sorgen muss, wo Server reingeschraubt, ziemlich teure Server sogar reingeschraubt werden müssen, sogar noch Softwarelizenzen für diese Betriebssysteme, die da drauf laufen und die Pakete austauschen. Und das macht dann schon richtig Geld, was dann auch wieder dazu führt, dass Leute, die da Investitionen getätigt haben, die wollen da schon wieder Geld wieder sehen.
Was so ein Berliner Rechen-Internet-Exchange-Ding kostet?
Also beim Internet-Exchange ist nochmal ein Unterschied zwischen, also das, wovon wir jetzt gerade geredet haben, waren Rechenzentren. Und da, wenn man jetzt so mittelgroß ist, dann redet man nicht von einzelnen Servern, die man da mietet, sondern man holt sich das schränkeweise. Und da zahlt man halt einen sogenannten Footprint, das ist halt dann irgendwie eine Fläche, einen Meter lang, einen 6 cm breiten, da kann man dann so einen Rack drauf stellen, was halt ein Schrank ist, der genau genormt ist von den Breiten her.
Das heißt, dann muss man seine eigene Hardware mitbringen oder die ist dann wieder zur Verfügung gestellt?
Das ist dann halt völlig unterschiedlich. Also man kann zum Beispiel zu Hetzner gehen, da kann man überhaupt keine Racks mieten, da holt man sich nur einen Server. Oder man geht jetzt halt ganz eigen hin und holt sich einen eigenen Server, kauft sich den und geht dann zu einem Provider und sagt, ich möchte den jetzt bei euch gern verbauen und schieb den da in einen Rack. Oder man geht halt noch eine Ebene drunter, mietet sich ein eigenes Rack, legt sich dann eigene Kabel da rein, um das Internet in das Rack zu bekommen und kauft sich eigene Hardware dafür und ist dann völlig unabhängig.
Ja, aber dann stehe ich ja wieder vor dem Problem, dass ich nur eine Leitung habe, die so einen schmalen Upload hat. Das ist ja für mein eigenes, kleines Internet Exchange Projekt nicht so geil. Wie krieg ich denn da eine richtige Leitung?
Ja, ein Rechenzentrum, da ist zum Beispiel der Datenaustausch überhaupt nicht über sowas wie DSL, sondern da hat man dann irgendwie in der Regel Glasfaser-Kabel, die dann von dem einen Provider zum anderen gehen. Und da gehen dann gleich meistens also normalerweise so 1 Gigabit oder 10 Gigabit oder 40 oder 100 Gigabit drüber. Und darüber bezieht man dann halt sogenannten Upstream.
Müssen diese Anbieter eigentlich, also wir haben ja so Flatrates angeblich, was dann immer heißt, ja, vielleicht bis 100 Gigabyte am Tag, dann schalten wir ab oder so. Da gibt es ja bei verschiedenen Anbietern verschiedene Dinge. Wie ist denn das in diesen Rechenzentren? Wird da auch überhaupt noch nach Datentransfer abgerechnet oder ist das eigentlich egal?
Ja, da rechnet man nicht nach transferierten Daten ab, sondern nach Bandbreite und über, also das nennt sich 95% Regel. Da wird dann irgendwie halt über den gesamten Monat aufgeschichtet, wann man wie viel übertragen hat. Das wird dann von der kleinsten zur größten Übertragungsrate, die im Schnitt war, aufgeschichtet und die obersten 5% werden weggeworfen. Und dann bezahlt man zum Beispiel 100 Megabits.
Das heißt zu sagen, wenn ich in einem Rechenzentrum Platz verbrauche, dann hab ich nicht einen festen monatlichen Betrag, sondern der ist immer anders.
Ja, du hast zum Beispiel entweder Inklusivtraffic, also bei den normalen Hostern hat man dann halt irgendwie einen Terabyte mit drinne und wenn man das voll hat, dann kriegt man nur noch weniger Bandbreite. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Provider ist, da sagt man dann, man hat jetzt hier eine Leitung, theoretisch einen Gigabit durch, aber man nimmt darauf jetzt nur 500 MBit ab. Und dann zahlt man diese 500 MBit und wenn man drüber ist, muss man wiederum jedes weitere MBit zahlen.
Aber du kannst natürlich alles verhandeln. Da gibt es reale Kosten und es gibt auch bei den Medien, die diese Pakete weiterleitet, bei dem Fall natürlich dann auch wieder dort, wo er peeren muss, also dort, wo er mit anderen Internet-Exchangen, mit anderen Leuten Daten austauscht, muss er natürlich auch wieder Gebühren bezahlen, sodass du dann üblicherweise dort in Verhandlungen trittst, ob du ihm dann auch Pakete wieder in die andere Richtung durchleitest, wenn du noch mit anderen Leuten peerst, sodass das dann einfach nach einer Weile einfach eine Verhandlungssache ist. Und es gibt einige Leute, die dort sich da auch schon hinstellen und sagen, aber von uns kommt auch ganz viel spannender Traffic, den deine Benutzer zum Beispiel ganz dringend klicken wollen. Und wäre ja total schade, wenn die dann wie ganz langsam das Internet noch zu dir hätten. Und vielleicht willst du ja nicht denn doch mal darüber nachdenken, da mit dem Preis ein bisschen runterzugehen.
Okay, aber das Spannende, was ich gerade lerne, ist, für uns als normale User klingt es ja oft so, die tatsächlich Übertragung von Daten kostet ja eigentlich nichts mehr, weil davon gibt es so viel. Das ist aber tatsächlich nicht der Fall, sondern tatsächlich ist es immer noch so, dass ein einzelnes Datum, das übertragen wird, auch Kosten verursacht. Und dass es einfach nur mittlerweile so viel davon gibt, dass es sich quasi bei einem einzelnen Bit um einen 0, 000 Cent Betrag hat.
Wir können ja mal ganz offen darüber sprechen. Wir haben jetzt für den DSL Betreiber, haben wir jetzt schon rausgefunden, dass der hat Kosten beim Verbuddeln des Kabels bei dir zu Hause, beim Hinliefern deiner Hardware, dein kleines Plastirouters und beim Betrieb von Kundenservices sind schon mal Kosten, die er auf jeden Fall hat. Aber dann verkauft er dir ja sowas wie hier 50 Megabit Flat. Und wenn du diese 50 Megabit Flat jetzt in so einem Internet Exchange bei irgendjemanden einkaufen müsstest, dann hättest du da ganz reale Kosten, komm drauf und dich wieder abnimmst, aber so mindestens drei Euro bezahlst du dafür, ein Megabit schon. Das heißt, wenn dir irgendjemand 50 Megabit zu dir nach Hause anbietet, dann müsste der dort 150 Euro am Internet Exchange latzen, um dir wirklich diese 50 Megabit garantiert nach Hause liefern zu können. Das heißt, dass da also eine Mischkalkulation stattfindet, das heißt, dass die Oma, die bei dir im Haus wohnt und zweimal am Tag ins Internet geht und sich ihre Mails abliefert, danach wieder den Rechner ausschaltet, dass die ja dasselbe bezahlt, was du bezahlst, eigentlich auch theoretisch 50 Megabit hat. Aber wenn du die 50 Megabit voll ausnutzst, dann bezahlt deine Oma im Nachbarhaus, querfinanziert dir dann deine Internetleitung mit.
Jetzt ist aber so, dass diese Kosten für das übertragene Megabyte oder G-Arbeit sagen, das sind aufrechnete Kosten, irgendwie Strom für den Server, Mietplatz in dem Platz, wo es steht, Betriebskosten, Leute, die darauf aufpassen.
Es gibt irgendwie Leute, die die Kabel verbuddelt haben oder versenkt haben im Ozean, die haben da schon sehr krasse initiale Investitionen geliefert und die fahren ja auch immer wieder raus, um noch schnellere Kabel zu versenken. Und die vermieten es dir dann auch wieder zu Konditionen. Die wollen dann natürlich auch, das machen sie ja nicht aus reiner Philanthropie, diese Kabel zu versenken, sondern die wollen dann... Und da ist irgendwie auch schon ein ganz realer, ja, so ein Brückenzoll, so eine Maut, die du da mit noch entrichten musst, um dieses einmal finanzierte Projekt eines versenkten Unterseekabels dann wieder am Ende reinzubekommen. Und in Neuseeland zum Beispiel, wo ich zu Besuch war bei jemandem, der sich echt doll überlegt, ob es für ihn jetzt cleverer ist, eine DVD im Laden zu kaufen oder per Bitthorn runterzuladen, weil dort gibt es irgendwie nur so einen Kabel. Sie versuchen da gerade ein zweites zu verlegen, aber es gibt ja nur einen Kabel in die USA und das ist irgendwie auch ziemlich teuer und kostet so 50 Euro Cent pro Gigabyte, Dinge runterzuladen. Das ist einfach so der Preis bei denen in Neuseeland, weil sie halt nur ein dünnes, schmales Kabel haben. Und da kostet lustigerweise das Internet aus der Luft genauso viel. Weil es macht keinen großen Unterschied mehr, ob du dort mit deinem Mobiltelefon so viel Traffic verursachst oder bei dir zu Hause per DSL. Und die legen dann noch mal zusammen. Also die gucken dann die aktuelle US-amerikanische Serie jetzt inzwischen nur. Einer lädt dann immer runter und dann wird es lokal weiterverteiltweise.
Der Spruch Raubkopieren lohnt sich nicht, bekommt dann völlig neue Bedeutung. Eine Frage hab ich noch zu den Internet Exchange. Ihr habt jetzt immer so von Server und Dingens gesprochen. Das ist so eine vermischtig bei mir gerade. Ist es eigentlich dasselbe, ob ich irgendwo einen Web-Server hoste oder ob ich Platte in einem Internet Exchange beanspruche?
Ich glaube, bei den Internet Exchange, die jetzt bitte durcheinander kommen, einmal, wenn du in so einem Rechenzentrum bist, kannst du halt zu einem Provider gehen und dir dort ein Upstream kaufen. Das kann man bei mehreren machen. Zum Beispiel bei der Deutschen Telekom, bei Telia und diversen anderen. Und man kann dann an einen Internet Exchange sich einen Port holen. Da rächt man dann der Regel nicht über Transferraten ab, sondern man mietet sich nur den Port, den Steckplatz für das Kabel sozusagen. Und da zahlt man dann irgendwie im Monat x 100 Euro. Und darüber spricht man sich dann sozusagen mit den Nachbarn ab. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, du willst zu Google, gibts google.de ein. Und dann geht das über dein ISP auf den Upstream drauf. Und der transportiert das dann weiter. Wenn Google jetzt zum Beispiel ein Rechenzentrum in Berlin hat und auch in einem Inter-Exchange klemmt und du auch da, wird dann sozusagen die Abkürzung genommen. Das ist unter einem kostengünstiger und auch wahrscheinlich latentstechnisch günstiger, dann den Traffic so direkt zu nehmen. Und so gibt es dann halt die großen in London, Amsterdam und Frankfurt. Da hängen dann halt Leute aus der ganzen Welt dran. Zum Beispiel, da sind in Frankfurt dann Router angeschlossen, die in Miami stehen. Und dann gibt es die kleinen Regionalen, wo dann zum Beispiel hier in Berlin die Berliner ISPs alle untereinander dranhängen. Und wenn man zum Beispiel dann bei dem einen Berliner ISP einen Server stehen hat und bei dem anderen, dann verlässt dieser Traffic gar nicht Berlin, sondern wird direkt unter den anderen ausgetauscht.
Ja, wir kommen da bald noch zu den CDNs. Aber vorher wollte ich noch auf deine Frage zurück. Da hast du ja erst gefragt, was man, wenn man so einen Server mit seinem Blog, das man hosten möchte, dahinstellt, dann optimiert man auf andere Kennengrößen. Da würde man üblicherweise nicht sich da so jetzt mehrere Dutzend Ports, also rein physikalische Ethernet Ports, in seinen Rechner rein patchen wollen, sondern würde man eher eine Platte wollen. Eine Platte ist ganz nützlich, wenn du so einen Blog betreibst, wenn du so einen Router hast, wo so ein Cisco-Betriebssystem draufläuft, was dann Pakete in die Gegend verteilt.
Worüber redest du gerade?
Ich rede darüber, was du für Hardware üblicherweise ins Rechenzentrum stellst, wenn du auf der einen Seite routen möchtest, einfach nur um dein kleines Rechenzentrum selber autark ans Netz anzubinden oder wenn du einen Blog betreiben möchtest. Oder einen Server mit lauter virtuellen Servern drauf oder deinen eigenen TeamSpeak Server irgendwo hinstellen. Dann würdest du natürlich eher irgendwas machen, wo normale Betriebssysteme drauf flutschig laufen. So was mit ordentlich...
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt deinen Blog hosten willst, dann nimmst du dir einen kleinen Server, machst da einen Linux drauf oder meinetwegen auch einen Windows Server und host dann deinen Blog darauf, nimmst dann eine Kiste, die hat irgendwie einen Netzwerkport und die geht auf einen Switch von deinem Hoster. Aber der Hoster zum Beispiel hat dann halt Router und Switches, die halt eigentlich nur darauf optimiert sind, Daten von A nach B zu schicken. Also es kommt auf Kabel 1 rein, geht auf Kabel 2 wieder raus. Und der sucht dann halt auch automatisch den günstigsten Weg zum nächsten.
Ich möchte es dann mal so versuchen zusammenzufassen, wie ich es jetzt verstanden habe, und das möglicherweise auch so versteht von Leuten, die da keine Ahnung haben. Ihr sagt genau das richtig. Also der Server zum Web-Posting ist quasi ein richtiger Computer, wie wir ihn von zu Hause kennen, ohne vielleicht das schöne Gehäuse, aber hat halt irgendwie so Prozessor, RAM, Festplatten und irgendwie so auch einen Netzwerkanschluss, wo halt der Internetwerk herausgeht.
Also die sind zollbreit, so zwei, drei Zentimeter hoch und gut durchlüftet und super laut, aber kein großer Unterschied zum Computer, den man auch zu Hause hat, außer dass sie leistungsfähiger sind.
Und die anderen Sachen, sozusagen um teilzunehmen an einem großen Netzwerkeverkehr, das ist quasi eine Ansammlung von Netzwerkkarten.
Genau, eine Netzwerkkarte in Gehäusen, wo dann ein spezielles Betriebssystem draufläuft, das nur auf Netzwerkdaten hin und her schieben optimiert wurde.
Alles klar, habe ich jetzt verstanden. Ihr hoffentlich auch, wenn nicht, ruft ihr an. 033 177 97 110. Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und ein bisschen Musik von Freiheit hören wir jetzt. Und das ist einer der Songs, die vom Free Music Sampler 2012 mit aufgenommen worden sind. Sehr schöne Geschichte dahinter auch, die Musik, der Sampler ist gerade rausgekommen und die Leute streiten sich auch gerade mit der GEMA, ob man nämlich für Creative Commons Musik auch bezahlen soll. Das Gericht hat erstmal gesagt, ja, mal gucken, was da noch passiert. Wir hören jetzt erstmal ein Titel aus genau diesem Sampler. Tapete, kennt ihr vielleicht von Anzeint, da sind die häufiger schon gewesen. Jetzt sind sie auch auf dem Free Music Sampler Freedom and Free Beer mit dem Song von Freiheit nicht genug. Wir werden diesen Sampler noch ausführlicher vorstellen, den Trackback, aber erst nächste Woche, weil diese Woche ja Samstag kein Trackback ist, weil da die neuen Deutsch Poeten stattfinden. Jetzt sind wir im Chaos Radio Imble Moon mit Erdgeist und Kay. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Willkommen zurück.
Und wir sprechen heute über das Internet und wie es funktioniert, nicht technisch, sondern wer da so als Firma mit dran beteiligt ist, als Player. Wir haben schon gelernt, wie die letzte Meile aufgeteilt und verkauft wird. Wir haben gelernt, was das Datenpaket, wenn es aus eurer Wohnung raus ist und durch die letzte Meile durch dann macht. Nämlich, es steht in einem sogenannten Internet Exchange Center auf. Das heißt, alle Firmen, die in einem bestimmten lokalen Gebiet irgendwas mit Internet machen, stellen dort ihre Rechner rein und verteilen die Datenverkehrer untereinander und routen sie auch quasi nach draußen. Zum Beispiel in so einem Übersiegelkabel, was echt teuer ist. Und bevor wir, ich muss jetzt, ich bin hier die ganze Zeit schon ganz gierig drauf, dass wir über CDNs reden.
Noch eine Korrektur. Das sind nicht Internet Exchanges, sondern sind Rechenzentren oder Co-Locations, nennt man sie. Und dort drin stehen zum Beispiel neben den Hostern auch Internet Exchanges.
Das ist bis jetzt auch nicht klar geworden.
Also ein Internet Exchange ist eigentlich nichts anderes als einen Switch, wie in jeder Zuhause zum Verteilen vom Internet benutzt hinter dem WLAN Router. Nur, dass die Switches halt viel größer sind und viel mehr können. Aber im Grunde ist das nur ein Verteiler und alle können darüber sprechen. Und das ist auch nur ein Kasten in einem Schrank, in einem Haus, was eine Klima hat.
Jetzt würde ich glaube ich aber, bevor wir zum CDN kommen, tatsächlich noch mal über das Übersiegkabel sprechen wollen, weil das ja so tierisch teuer ist. Dass er den Datenverkehr, wie der Herr Erdgeist schon häufig angemerkt hat, jetzt so teuer macht, weil man da so viele Investitionen reingelegt, rein versenkt hat und die dann irgendwann wieder auszahlen. Kann einer von euch mal beschreiben, wie so ein Untersiegkabel eigentlich aussieht, was so, keine Ahnung, Europa und Amerika verbindet?
Ja, so ein Unterseekabel ist in der Regel, also die allerersten waren noch Kupferkabel, aber inzwischen sind das alles Glasfaserkabel. Das ist dann irgendwie ein riesig fettes Bündel mit mehreren hundert Glasfasern. Die werden dann wieder rüber einfach in einem dicken Mantel verlegt, der irgendwie mit Stahlgewebe ist, dass das nicht schnell kaputt geht, dass da auch mal ein Hai reinbeißen kann oder so.
Ah, Kabel.
Und dann gibt es da halt verschiedene Punkte. Normalerweise läuft das halt so an der Küste lang, das Kabel, und hat dann immer so Stichstellen rein ins Land und kann dann an verschiedenen Punkten abgegriffen werden oder Sachen dazugespeist werden können. Und dann gibt es da noch Repeater drin, weil man kann jetzt nicht das in der einen Seite in die Glasfaser reinleuchten und es kommt in Amerika raus, sondern man muss das mehr darüber mehrfach verstärken und deswegen läuft da auch noch Strom mit in dem Kabel, um diese Repeater zu betreiben, die dann alle paar hundert Kilometer stehen und das Signal verstärken.
Da gibt es auch eine Karte im Internet, da kann man sich mal so visualisieren, wie da diese Kabel um die Welt herum verlegt sind.
Genau, und zwar ist das cablemap.info, da seht ihr eine Weltkarte und ganz viele Linien und da seht ihr mal grob, wie viele Kabel da so verlegt sind und da steht auch, wenn man dann auf einen Strich draufklickt, wie viel Bandbreite darüber geht, es sind mehrere Terabits zum Beispiel.
Und jetzt haben wir in die Sendung angefangen, dass ihr gesagt habt, so ein Kabel wurde irgendwie beschädigt. Legen die dann einfach auf dem Meerboden da rum oder wie ist das?
Mehr oder weniger, ja. Also die Kabel werden halt einfach auf einem Schiff hinten transportiert und dann ins Wasser geworfen und dann sinken sie runter in der Regel und liegen dann halt da.
Also Küstner werden sie dann schon noch, teilweise werden da noch Graben gebuddelt, dann werden die da reingelassen, dann werden sie wieder zugebuddelt und dann ist wie genau an Land, dass du dann aufpassen musst, dass irgendwie verbuddelt, heißt ja nicht verbuddelt, wenn da so ein großes Schiff vorbeikommt, da sein Anker einfach unter unter Wasser dann auf den Grund lässt und dann wieder losfährt, vergisst den Anker hochzunehmen.
Das passiert mehrfach im Jahr, dass irgendwer irgendwie ein Kabel beschädigt und ja, dann ist das Kabel durch oder beschädigt, dann muss halt ein Schiff wieder rauskommen, das fährt dann dahin, sucht die kaputte Stelle, sucht das Kabel, holt das ans, zieht das dann hoch und guckt sich an und repariert es.
Das sind irgendwie einige der kompliziertesten internationalen Verträge, die da so geschlossen werden können, sind so überhaupt Kabel, die man durchs Meer zieht, weil das ja nicht nur jetzt Netzwerkkabel, die da so Glasfarbepfaser zwischen den Kontinenten, sondern auch Stromkabel, so aus deinen Offshore, neu gebauten Offshore-Windkraftwerken zum Beispiel. Und da ist ja dann plötzlich, wenn du mehrere Kabel liegst, die sich auch noch kreuzen, dann ist ja immer eins oben. Und wenn einer seins flicken möchte, dann ist plötzlich das andere oben. Und wenn es irgendwie mal kaputt gegangen ist, dann sieht man die hoch, knurrt man sie wieder zusammen und lässt sie wieder runter. Und dann plötzlich musst du die Verträge wieder ändern, weil die Wartung von so Kabeln, die da so untereinander liegen, schon echt komplex ist.
Und deswegen ist es auch toll, dieses Kabel zu benutzen. Und das heißt ja sagen, wenn ich jetzt anfange, auf meinem Rechner eine Webseite zu klicken, sagen wir mal.
Was du so tust, wenn du hochauflösende Vorplantungsdokumenten.
Oder du klickst zum Beispiel bei deinem Rechner auf Update und er zieht sich mal die aktuellen Software Sachen runter.
Von linux.com irgendwo aus US Amerika.
Genau, dann sagen, ich würde jetzt mal kurz sagen, beschreiben wollen, ihr sagt, ob ich was falsch gemacht habe, von dem, was ich bis jetzt ziemlich gelernt habe. Und da würde man ja denken, so okay, also ich sitze irgendwo in Berlin. In Berlin geht das Ding durch die Wand, geht dann halt in so eine Co-Location-Server-Ding, wo auch ein Internet Exchange steht, der guckt sich das Paket an, stellt fest, ja, haben wir leider keinen hier, der irgendwie jetzt so Dings ist, das sitzt in Amerika. Schickt dann also das Paket raus, das geht dann über weitere so Internet Exchanges, bisschen dieses Tiefseekabel, was total teuer ist und lang. Wieso nicht?
Das Internet Exchange ist wirklich nur so ein Austauschpunkt, das kann man so vergleichen mit irgendwie einem schwarzen Brett, wo jeder dran schreibt, was er hat und wie man da hinkommt. Davor gibt es dann noch mal Provider, die schließen sich. Also du gehst dann hin und gibst deine Daten, einen Provider und der kümmert sich dann darum, dass es zum Beispiel zu dem Internet Exchange geht oder er transportiert das durch sein eigenes Unterseekabel nach Amerika, weil er dort mit jemand verbunden ist, der den Content hat. Und die Internet Exchanges sind dann nur so ein neutraler Knotenpunkt, die eine Plattform bieten zum Austausch. Und da gehen dann die Provider hin, mieten sich den Port drauf und tauschen dann die Daten mit anderen Providern aus.
Und wieso kommt da mein Paket nicht vorbei?
Es muss nicht vorbeikommen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt...
Wir sind jetzt gerade beim Beispiel, mein Paket will nach Amerika.
Genau. Und nach Amerika hast du jetzt keinen an deinem... Also du bist jetzt zum Beispiel ein kleiner Provider hier in Berlin, bist an einem Internet Exchange in Berlin angeschlossen. Und da hast du jetzt zum Beispiel nicht eine Firma aus Amerika, weil das halt nur ein sehr kleiner Kreis ist, der da angeschlossen ist. Also nur ein Bruchteil vom Internet. Aber du hast dann halt weitere Upstreams. Zum Beispiel, ja, Deutsche Telekom, Global Crossing oder Telia. Und denen gibst du dann die Daten. Und die haben wiederum so ein großes Netz, das um die ganze Welt reicht. Und die transportieren das dann für dich weiter.
Aber das ist doch, sagen wir, trotzdem auf diesem Internet Exchange ausgetauscht worden, oder nicht?
Nee. Also du kannst entweder auswählen, es geht über einen Internet Exchange. Oder du gibst es einem Uplink-Provider, so genannt er.
Das wird jetzt zu kompliziert. Wir können ja einfach mal versuchen, zu sagen, da ist irgendwie noch mehr, da ist so tief, wenn man nicht reinleuchtet, das wird dann ganz schnell ziemlich verwoben. Man kann ja wieder einfach halber einfach mal sagen, dass es so ungefähr auch funktioniert, dass man die Preise, die jetzt die Durchleitung bei diesen Upstream-Providern, dass man die vergleicht mit dem, was man vielleicht bei den lokalen Zixen dort bezahlen würde und sich dann den günstigsten Anbieter raussucht und am Ende sich nicht weiter darum kümmert, wo das Paket wirklich landet, sondern einfach sagt, ich hab hier ein Internetpaket und ich würde jetzt gerne das über den billigsten Anbieter verschicken und dann gibt's dann Algorithmen, die einem das ausrechnen, was da grad der optimale Weg ist. Aber auch am Ende ist natürlich dann der Preis, den das nimmt, ist eine der Metriken. Du willst ja deinen Kunden auch nicht unbedingt einen Paket nach dem günstigsten Preis nur zumuten. Wenn das dann einfach so durch die billigsten Anbieter kommt, aber dann da so mehrere Sekunden Latenz plötzlich hat, ist es wie eine schlechte Metrik, einfach nur den Preis daherzunehmen, sondern du misst da mal alles Mögliche auf und hast dann am Ende rausgefunden, dass dein Kunde sehr unzufrieden ist, wenn er sich jetzt die Tierdokumentation dort mit einer Bandbreite von nur 10 Kilobit pro Sekunde nach Hause ziehen kann. Also will er wahrscheinlich dort mal eine dicke Bandbreite haben und ist wahrscheinlich auch bereit, dafür dann Geld zu bezahlen für andere Dinge. Will er halt dann vielleicht nicht so schnell ist oder vielleicht, wie geht das auch mit größer Latenz noch in Ordnung?
Aber das ist dann eine Mischkalkulation, die der Provider wieder macht. Weil sagen, ich als Kunde bezahle immer nur einen Preis.
Du kannst auch gar nicht entscheiden.
Als Kunde würde es dann vielleicht im Zweifel eher weggehen, wenn irgendwie bei mir zu Hause geht Skype langsam. Wenn bei der Telekom ging es aber voll schnell, dann gehe ich halt woanders hin. Also man kann natürlich seinem Kunden irgendwie so Dinge zumuten, bis das Kamell platzt.
Ja genau, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, das entscheidet der Provider, das berechnet ihm nicht einzeln, sondern zu sagen, ich bezahle meine 20 Euro und der Provider entscheidet dann so, okay, die Leute, die da wohnen, die gucken alle viele hochauflösende Fortplantungsdokumentationen, aber skypen wenig, deswegen sozusagen können wir das so. Und wenn er sich dann falsch entscheidet, dann sagt der Kunde so, ich geh mal weg. Okay, aber ich als Kunde sehe das nicht, wie er sich entschieden hat. Merkt das höchstens, wenn er sich falsch entschieden hat.
Nun hast du aber das Problem, dass viele von den Informationen, die so Leute sich besorgen wollen, auch identisch sind. Also wenn plötzlich viele Leute in der Welt gleichzeitig sich die neue Version des Betriebssystems herunterladen möchten, dann hast du sowohl als Provider, der den Kunden das jetzt zukommen lassen möchte, als auch derjenige, der es anbietet, hast du so ein Problem. Da gibt es so Möglichkeiten, das zu lösen. BitTorrent zum Beispiel ist aber so für eine garantierte Qualität, die du deinen Kunden liefern möchtest, jetzt nicht so immer die optimale Wahl. Und dann gibt es andere Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel ein...
Also ein CDN ist eine Firma meistens, die ich halt... Halt.
Was heißt CDN?
Stimmt. Das heißt Content Delivery Network. Also die verteilen sozusagen den Inhalt. Und wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel eine Firma hingeht, die jetzt ein Update rausbringt für ihr Betriebssystem, das ist dann irgendwie einen Gigabyte groß. Und die wollen natürlich, dass alle das richtig schnell bekommen. Und die haben jetzt aber nur ihre Server in Amerika, in ihrer Zentrale stehen. Und die übergeben dann dieses Paket mit dem neuen Betriebssystem drinne, so im CDN, die haben in der ganzen Welt verteilt kleine Inseln. In Rechenzentren haben sie dann irgendwie zehn Racks, randvoll mit Server, mit viel Platten und ganz schnell angebunden. Und haben davon in jeder Stadt einstehen. Oder sogar in manchen Providern drinne. Also zum Beispiel bei deinem DSL Provider steht dann auch so mehrere Schränke von diesem Content Delivery Network. Und die kümmern sich darum, dass der Content dann auf allen diesen Servern ist und somit ganz, ganz nah beim Kunden.
So, was der Kunde dann sieht ist, er macht eine Anfrage im DNS, also bei Name Server und fragt, sag mal, wo steht eigentlich updates.microsoft.com? Und dann guckt dein Name Server, der bei deinem Provider eingetragen ist, guckt nach und sagt, ja gut, jetzt könnte ich dir sagen, der ist in Amerika, will ich aber grad nicht, sondern updates.microsoft.com steht hier. Bei mir lokal, wie mit dieser IP-Adresse kannst du runterladen. Und man würde sich dann einfach zu einem Rechner dieser Content Delivery Networks hinconnecten und würde dann am Ende über die Signatur rausfinden müssen, das ist wirklich korrekt, das ist wirklich Microsoft und würde dann anfangen statt über das teure Überseekabel, dieses Update runterzuladen, dann einfach von dem Server, den da dieser CDN bei deinem Provider hingestellt hat, direkt anfangen runterzuladen.
Das kann man auch beobachten, wenn man bei Videos, das fällt das glaube ich oft an, wenn man so kleine Firewall-Programme auf seinem Rechner laufen hat, dann fragt das manchmal, obwohl man sich jetzt zu hochauflösende fortpflanzungsdokumentation.de verbunden hat, nach so einer ganz kruden Nummer, so ehe entlange Namen stehen, möglicherweise so was wie Akamai drin oder sowas. Das ist dann so ein Content Delivery Network Server.
Ja, es gibt einfach zwei große gerade und Akamai ist einer der ersten, die da drauf gekommen sind. Die haben irgendwann, war glaube ich ein Universitätsprojekt und dann hat Apple noch ganz früh darin investiert, die da Webobjekts sich ausgedacht haben und dort jetzt für ihre ersten Updates und ich glaube ihre ersten Versuche mit dem iTunes Music Store wollten sie selber machen, sondern wollten sie einkaufen und haben sie an Akamai investiert. Und war auch irgendwie das erste Geld, was dann damals Apple auch wieder verdient hatte, nachdem es ihnen schlecht ging, glaube ich. Und die sind irgendwie so einer der ersten großen Spieler und die hatten irgendwie dann ziemlich schlaue Algorithmen, um rauszufinden, was denn jetzt gerade heiße Files sind. Also Files, die gerade ganz viel von Leuten aus einer Region angefragt worden sind, weil du hast natürlich wieder eine andere Metrik. Du kannst ja nicht das gesamte Angebot deines Kunden jetzt überall spiegeln, was gar nicht angefragt wird. Sondern musst irgendwie schon schauen, was sind gerade, wenn in Deutschland so die Leute vom Update Server nur die deutsche Version des Betriebssystems wollen, dann kann man natürlich da schon vorbauen und sich auf der Seite des Anbieters dafür darum kümmern, dass irgendwie jetzt nur das deutsche Sprachpaket damit bei ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite will man das eigentlich auch Algorithmen machen lassen. Wenn du siehst, dass dasselbe Pfeil aus der Region Deutschland in ein paar Millionenfach angefragt ist, dann kriegt das Content-Delivery-Network das mit und holt sich das dann einmal aus US-Amerika und sorgt dann dafür, dass wenn alle anderen dasselbe Pfeil haben wollen, dass das dann eher lokal ausgeliefert wird.
Das hört sich ja sozusagen nach einer recht menschenfreundlichen, ideellen Vorgehensweise an, dass das Content-Delivery-Network sagt, hey, ihr wollt alle diese Datei haben, kein Problem, ich hol sie euch und leg sie bei uns drauf. Aber da muss doch irgendjemand dafür bezahlen. Wer?
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder sehr unterschiedlich. Also eigentlich zahlt dann am Ende der, der sagt, ich hab hier meine Datei, die muss verteilt werden. Und dann bezahlt er dafür, dass die zum Beispiel überall in bestimmter Geschwindigkeit verfügbar ist.
Ach so, das läuft dann sozusagen nicht so, dass er sagt, ich möchte, dass diese Datei gerade verteilt wird. Und dann wird die sozusagen nach seinem Willen auf bestimmte Server dieses CDNs hochgeladen, sondern er sagt das und dass die CDN-Firma hat einen Algorithmus, der ausrechnet, wo diese Dateien verteilt werden müssen.
Genau, also man sagt dann zum Beispiel, was für eine Art ist, wenn das jetzt zum Beispiel für die Fußballwende oder Olympiade ist, dann wird gesagt, das ist ein Livestream. Und der kann dann zum Beispiel, weil dann gerade Deutschland spielt, kann sein, dass jetzt ganz viel in Deutschland dafür gebraucht wird, aber wenig Kapazität woanders. Und dann kümmert sich, also das CDN ist dann, er kennt das und kümmert sich darum, dass in Deutschland dafür genügend Kapazitäten vorhanden sind.
Aber der sozusagen der Auftraggeger sagt tatsächlich nur, ich habe hier diesen Inhalt und ich möchte, dass der überall auf der Welt oder sozusagen, er kann noch das Gebiet anschränken wahrscheinlich.
Genau, er sagt dann die Zielgruppe ist zum Beispiel in Europa und das möchten wir da, dass das zu dieser Uhrzeit live geht auf allen Knoten und alle sollen das schnell runterladen können.
Das ist ja erstmal eine sehr gute Einrichtung, könnte man sagen, aber hat das auch einen Nachteil, also was ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen kann, dass die sich wirtschaftlich in einer sehr guten Position irgendwann befinden. Also wenn er gerade auch sagt, es gibt noch irgendwie so zwei große Player in dem Feld, wenn die dann irgendwie sagen, ja nö, lass mal die Preise erhöhen, dann haben ja eigentlich die Firmen schlechte Karten, oder?
Du hast dann ja auch nur ein bestimmtes Budget dafür. Also wir haben ja am Anfang die Frage gestellt, wer bezahlt eigentlich das Internet? Und was wir gerade rausgefunden haben, sind Leute, die da wirklich ihr Geld reintun können. Sind auf der einen Seite die Leute, die zu Hause ihr DSL haben wollen. Wir haben auch gesehen, dass in den ganzen Mischkalkulationen, da immer nur ziemlich wenig Luft drin ist, da kannst du dich beliebig an einer Preisschraube drehen und dann gehen die Preise auch herunter. Und die anderen Leute sind die, die irgendwo Server mieten. Und das machen sie ja meistens auch nicht, um dann wie nur Server rumstehen zu haben, sondern die wollen dann wie Geschäfte betreiben oder hoffen da am Ende auch wieder, ein Business mit dem Internet irgendwie zu machen oder das Geld reinzubekommen. Und da kannst du auch nicht beliebig an der Stellschraube hochdrehen, weil dann sich das auch nicht mehr lohnen würde, weil der Empfänger auf der anderen Seite dem Internet ja auch nicht beliebig Lust hat, für die Produkte dann mehr Geld noch drauf zu bezahlen. Also trotzdem ist das Geld, was erstmal drin ist, wird jetzt natürlich auch mit harten Bandagen verteilt. Also, ich weiß nicht, es gibt einige... Na ja, es gab da so Hin- und Heereffekte, dass zum Beispiel gab es vor zwei Jahren so eine Geschichte in Großbritannien, wo die DSL-Provider plötzlich der Meinung waren, die BBC macht aber mit ihren ganzen HD-Dokumentationen, die sich alle Leute jetzt runterladen, also wirkliche Tierdokumentation, machen sie so viel Traffic bei unseren Kunden und die wollen uns alle runterladen, jetzt wollen wir mal damit, wie die BBC noch ordentlich durchleiten, von der BBC Geld dafür sehen. Ja, und die BBC hat sich hingestellt, brrr, nee. Und dann war das dann auch ziemlich schnell gegessen. Dann war dieser Blöff dann auch ziemlich schnell aufgerufen. Und auf der anderen Seite sieht es jetzt so aus, dass eher Leute, die Content zur Verfügung stellen, in sich einer starken Verhandlungsposition fühlen und meinen, ja, wir sind Google, wir haben irgendwie diesen YouTube-Service und eure Kunden wollen bestimmt ganz schnell YouTube gucken können und die werden sich bestimmt auch beschweren, wenn es nicht sehr schnell durchgeht. Deswegen sind unsere Peering-Konditionen jetzt so und so.
Da kann man so zum Beispiel das Beispiel nehmen, bei diesem Provider, wenn Sie zwei Provider verknüpfen, zum Beispiel jetzt, wenn Kabel Deutschland mit Google jetzt zusammen sich verknüpft, damit die Daten schön schnell fließen. Das gibt es auch jetzt in, also normalerweise macht man das halt, weil es auf Gegenseitigkeit beruht. Der Content ist dann froh, dass er schnell beim Nutzer ist. Der Nutzer ist froh, dass er schnell beim Content ist und es wenig kostet. Aber zum Beispiel Deutsche Telekom, wenn man sich mit denen zusammenschalten will und entweder man ist einer von den richtig, richtig großen, dann sagt die Telekom, okay, wir sehen dann, wir sehen, dass es Geld kosten würde, aber wir machen jetzt das beide auf Gegenseitigkeit und berechnen nichts dafür. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel einer, der nicht der riesig großen in Deutschland ist, dann sagen die halt ganz einfach, hey, wenn du schnell bei unseren Kunden sein willst, dann bezahl doch dafür. Und genauso...
Das ist dann nicht mehr Netzneutralität, oder? Das ist jetzt die Frage, die mir jetzt so sein die ganze Zeit auf der Zunge liegt. Also diese Idee ist ja, dass alle gleich Inhalt immer gleich schnell sind, aber schon diese CDNs sind dann eigentlich eine Verletzung, dieses Prinzip.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, was die Telekom macht, das nennt sich einfach in der Branche paid peering, also bezahlte Zusammenkunft dann einfach.
Bisschen wir nach Prostitution an, ich kann mich grad nicht...
Ja, zum Beispiel von einem anderen großen CDN, da gibt's also die Regel so, wir schließen uns nicht mit kleinen Providern zusammen, außer sie tauschen irgendwie so und so 4 Gigabit mit uns aus. Oder sie zahlen Geld pro für die ausgetauschten Daten.
Das heißt, das ist schon auch so ein Markt, wo es halt nicht so einfach ist, mal zu sagen, okay, ich mach jetzt hier einfach noch meinen eigenen Provider. Weil von der technischen Seite klang das ja die ganze Zeit so wie, natürlich kannst du das machen und dir auch einen eigenen Server in so einen Call Location Space, also so ein Server-Haus reinstellen, aber wirtschaftlich oder sozusagen von der Geschwindigkeit her ist es nicht so einfach, weil die großen Player da gut zusammenhalten.
Ja, also es beruht halt sehr auf den anderen darin, dem ganzen Spiel und man erreicht auch als Kleiner relativ gut die anderen und wenn man halt zu einem bestimmten hin will, der jetzt einer der Großen ist, dann kann man ja sich zum Beispiel bei einem anderen Großen einkaufen und dann zum Beispiel von denen sagen, ich will von euch jetzt den Traffic haben, der zur deutschen Telekom fließt.
Okay, also muss man dann über Mittelsmann gehen. Jetzt haben wir diese CDNs endlich mal. Das wurde ja aber auch Zeit. Jetzt sind ja gleich schon wieder Nachrichten. Was bleibt uns denn noch, was wir in der letzten halben Stunde alles nicht mehr schaffen?
Wir sind eigentlich schon unsere Choreografie doch genau im Zeitplan geblieben. Du hast ja jetzt das Zettel doch da rumliegen, oder?
Jetzt hör mal auf mich so hinzustellen, als wäre ich nicht vorbereitet, was zwar stimmt, aber jetzt nicht an dieser Stelle immer erwähnt werden muss. Erdgeist! Okay, als Werbezeichen noch RIP. Könnt ihr schon kurz mal anteasern, was das ist?
Na, die vergeben so die Zahlen, also die Nummern, unter denen Rechner erreichbar ist im Internet.
Ach, wir können das aber generischer fassen. Im Laufe der Zeit hast du irgendwie wie im Wilden Westen da alle haben wie wild ihre Eisenbahnlinien durch die Gegend verlegt. Ein paar Leute bauen Straßen, ein paar Leute erschießen Indianer und irgendwann hast du doch nochmal eine Regulierung, die notwendig ist, um dort wieder ein bisschen Ordnung in diesen Wilden Westen dort rein zu schaffen. Irgendwann sind die IP-Adressen alle irgendwann, will man auch glaube ich dafür sorgen, dass es so ein paar grundsätzliche Spielregeln der Leute untereinander gibt, die dann von doch irgendwie eigentlich noch recht freundlich gesinnten Engineers dann so im halbwegs im Konsens da besprochen werden. Und diese Institutionen, die das regulieren, die wollen wir jetzt in der letzten halben Stunde ansprechen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Das Line-up ist komplett. Die Sonne ist bestellt. Und die geheimen Geheimgäste sind auch noch geheim. Eigentlich nur noch ihr, falls ihr noch kein Ticket habt.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das Fritz Open Air Festival. Mit TS. Ullmann, The Koleckis und Tim Bensko. Mit Timo Hauer, Vierkantretlager und Max Herren. Und dazu ein paar ziemlich geheime Geheimgäste.
Kommen am Samstag live von Open Air. In IFA Sommergarten auf dem Messegelände Berlin. Und auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten auch bei Fritz im Netz.
Oder ihr gewinnt sie bei uns. Einfach gut, Fritz Hör.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das Fritz Open Air Festival.
Moderiert.
Auf der Bühne.
Um kurz nach halb 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
Die Flugbegleiter der Lufthansa beginnen morgen ihren Streik in Frankfurt am Main. Das hat die Gewerkschaft UFO am späten Abend mitgeteilt. Der erste Ausstand des Kabinenpersonals in der Geschichte der Lufthansa soll demnach um 5 Uhr morgens beginnen und bis 13 Uhr dauern. Fluggäste müssen sich auf erhebliche Behinderungen und Flugausfälle einrichten. Wann der neue Hauptstadtflughafen tatsächlich eröffnet wird, soll erst nach der nächsten Aufsitzrat sich Sitzung der Flughafengesellschaft bekanntgegeben werden. Berlins regierender Bürgermeister Woverheit sagte dem RBB, dem neuen Technikchef Amann müsse die Zeit bis zum 14. September gegeben werden, um die Unterlagen intensiv zu prüfen. Die Flughafeneröffnung ist nach zwei gescheiterten Terminen für den 17. März 2013 vorgesehen. Fachleute bezweifeln jedoch, dass dieser Termin gehalten werden kann. Das Drama Barbara geht als deutscher Beitrag in den Wettbewerb um den Oscar 2013. Es geht um den Preis für den besten nicht englischsprachigen Film. Eine Fachjury in München hat sich für das Drama über eine ostdeutsche Ärztin entschieden. Schon bei der Berlinale 2012 bekam der Film von Regisseur Christian Petzold den silbernen Bären für die beste Regie. Der Iran hat nach Angaben der internationalen Atomenergieorganisation eine seiner Urananreicherungsanlagen beträchtlich erweitert. Die Zahl der Zentrifugen in dem unterirdischen Komplex sei seit Mai auf 2000 verdoppelt worden, heißt es in dem neuesten Bericht der Behörde. Der Westen wirft Teheran vor, nach Atomwaffen zu streben. Die iranische Regierung weist dies zurück und pocht auf ihr Recht zur friedlichen Nutzung der Atomenergie.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Buch haben wir 18 Grad, in Wannsee messen wir 20 Grad, in Cottbus sind es bloß noch 17, Potsdam, Frankfurt, Mittenberg in Europin, Angermünde 18 Grad. Bis zum Morgen ziehen jede Menge dichte Wolken samt Regen durch, teilweise kann es auch gewittern, und die Temperaturen gehen auch bis auf 13 Grad runter. Der Freitag wird dann stark bewölkt, und es gibt jede Menge Regen, maximal 12 Grad, nee, 20 sind immerhin drin. Am Wochenende wird es dann trotz Regenschauern wieder etwas freundlicher. Die Straßen sind scheinbar frei, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de fritz.de Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Heute Chaosradio mit Erdgeist und Kay, die ich das Internet erkläre, genauer wer darin Geld für was nimmt und bezahlen muss. Und auf Wunsch eines einzelnen Herrn, der heute hier anwesend ist, gibt es jetzt an dieser Stelle auch noch Musik und zwar einen Totentanz. Es ist ja ein nicht endwollendes Klischee, dass gerade Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Clubs nur Bitmusik hören. Ich habe in meiner langen Zeit hier als Chaos-Radio-Moderator gelernt, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist. Dass gerade solche Musik, wie wir gerade hier gehört haben, da sehr beliebt ist. Das war der Toten Dance von Caldron. Das ist Musik vom Free Music Sampler diesen Jahres, den Titel Freedom and Free Beer trägt, so nicht man sie auch runterladen kann. Link gibt es nach der Sendung im Blog zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. Da seid ihr nämlich im Chaos Radio zu Gastin Erdgeist und Kay. Hallo und willkommen zurück zur letzten, na ja, fast halben Stunde. Genau, wir sprechen gleich noch über das Thema, wer nämlich im Internet was und wie bezahlt und bezahlen kann. Vorher noch eine kleine News, die wir verbreiten wollen.
Es handelt sich um eine große Java-Lücke. Und ich persönlich fand das sehr ulkig, weil ein Kumpel mich vor drei Tagen darauf hingewiesen hat, dass ein ehemaliger Sun-Ingenieur, also diese Firma, die ziemlich coole Erfindungen wie zum Beispiel das ZFS und D-Trace gebaut hat, was eher Hacker interessiert, aber die haben auch Java erfunden. Und irgendwann ist diese Firma Sun, weil wenn Engineers so eine Firma versuchen, selber zu steuern, sind die auch in ein bisschen finanziell harte Zeiten gekommen und wurden dann von einer der echt bösen Firmen aufgekauft namens Oracle. Und Oracle hat als Ziel nicht so etwas wie Enabling People zu helfen, sondern einfach Geld verdienen und das zeigt sich jetzt, dass die da nicht so richtig mit der Community umgehen können, weil sie haben ihr Java so ein bisschen verrotten lassen und schon vor einem halben Jahr haben ein paar Sicherheitsforscher gesagt, ihr habt ein echtes Problem, euer Sandboxing im Browser funktioniert nicht, man kann irgendwie ziemlich einfach dem... Das heißt, dass der Browser sorgt natürlich dafür, dass irgendwas, was in deiner Webseite ausgeführt wird, nicht an deine privaten Familienfotos darf. Und sowas heißt Sandboxing, also man sperrt also ein Prozess an eine kleine Sandbox ein, in so einen Wuddelkasten, in dem darf es machen, was es möchte, aber an die Familienfotos darf es nicht ran. Und es gibt jetzt einen ganz einfachen Weg, sich so diese Sandkasten-Umgebung einfach kaputt zu spielen, außer aus diesem Java heraus und zu sagen, ich will aber doch und ich bin nämlich gar nicht aus dem Internet, sondern ich lag vorher schon auf der Festplatte, deswegen darf ich alles. Und das wurde der Firma Oracle schon vor einem halben Jahr mitgeteilt und die haben einfach Müscht gemacht. Und dazwischen sieht es so aus, dass wenn du mit deinem Browser auf irgendeiner Webseite vorbeikommst, wo ein Java-Ablett noch drin ist und du es nicht irgendwann schon mal ausgeschaltet hast, also wenn du Java in deinem Browser nicht irgendwie schon mal ausgeschaltet hast, hast du gerade ein Problem. So, egal auf welchen Betriebssystem, gerade mit welchem Browser, wenn du Java anhast, dann hast du ein Problem, dein Rechner ist sozusagen dann schon prinzipiell in fremder Hand. Und genau, das ging jetzt so in den letzten Tagen durch die Presse und es hat für mich dann auch wieder so den Eindruck bestätigt, dass einfach solche wichtige Kerninfrastruktur, die jetzt auch Java darstellt, weil es einfach in allen Browsern eingebaut ist, dann nicht in die Firma, in die Hände von so einer raffgierigen Firma wie Oracle gehört.
Man muss ja noch dazusagen, die Sicherheitslücke, das ist ja nicht so einfach. Also man kann bei vielen Browsern sagen, hier bitte kein Java mehr benutzen, außer beim Internet Explorer. Das hatten wir heute sogar in Nachrichten, dass es halt genau nicht geht. Hatten wir das in Nachrichten? Egal. Es war auf jeden Fall groß genug. Es gibt wohl eine Anleitung für den Internet Explorer, die ist aber so kompliziert, dass da wohl die normalen Leute nicht so richtig durchsteigen.
Da könnte man einfach gleich die Linux CD reinschieben, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen weniger kompliziert. Es gibt ja auch inzwischen Distributionen, die einfach für den Großteil der Anwender schon so window-isch aussehen, dass man da sich einfach kaum noch Ärger einhandelt. Also besser als Windows 98 ist es allemal.
Okay. Jetzt aber zurück zum Internet, wo wir heute schon gelernt haben, wie die letzte Meile gebaut und bezahlt wird, wie das Datenpaket von der letzten Meile in das erste Rechenzentrum und von dort auch immer weiterkommt und wie Inhalte, die sehr, sehr, sehr beliebt sind, verteilt werden, nämlich über sogenannte CDNs, Content Delivery Networks, wo halt Leute, Rechner in sozusagen lokalen Serverzentren stehen haben und sagen, okay, wenn der Inhalt total beliebt ist, bewerft ihr uns mit Geld, dann tun wir das dahin und dann ist das schneller bei euren Kunden. Das letzte, was wir im Internet noch klären wollen, ist das sogenannte RIPE. Wofür steht das eigentlich und was macht das?
Das RIPE ist eigentlich eine Organisation, die besteht eigentlich aus, grob gesagt, zwei Teilen. Einmal der Organisation, die das ausführt, was der andere Teil, die Community, sagt.
Und worum kümmern die sich, wenn es ums Internet geht?
Die kümmern sich drum um die Verteilung der IP-Adressen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel google.de eingibt, dann ist das in Wirklichkeit eine Adresse hinten, die heißt 1.2.3.4 als Beispiel. Ist jetzt nicht die echte. Und damit Google die benutzen darf, muss das halt zugeteilt werden. Und das passiert in Europa von der RIPE. Also weltweit gibt es da die IANA, die verwaltet diese gesamten Internetnummern und verteilt das dann an regionale Internet-Registrars. Und in Europa ist das das RIPE bzw. das RIPE NCC. Und da schreibt man zum Beispiel als ISP hin eine Mail. Man ist jetzt Member geworden und will jetzt gerne IP-Adressen haben. Man braucht so und so viele für die und die Sachen und dann bekommt man die zugeteilt.
Und das, weil es ja heute um Geld geht, kostet genau wie viel?
Das ist Unterschied. Also je nachdem, wie viele IP-Adressen man hat, wird man da eingestuft von extra small bis extra large. Und das kostet glaube ich im schlimmsten Fall irgendwie 10.000 Euro mehr.
Also nicht wirklich viel Geld.
Ab 150 war doch irgendwie, oder?
Also es kostet Geld, aber es ist im Rahmen dessen, wie viel man dann nimmt, eigentlich erträglich. Also wenn ich jetzt sagen, meinen eigenen Provider aufmachen will, ist das Bezahlen der IP-Adresse jetzt nicht der größte Posten.
Üblicherweise, wenn du deinen eigenen Provider aufmachen möchtest, kommt es wieder darauf an, ob du schon aus dem Netzblock, wo du deinen Rechner da reinstellst, weil die kaufen sich die ja dann so in größeren Paletten als du, immer so in Blöcken, die dadurch auch so zweier potenzen. Und dann sagst du dann du, ich brauch davon sowas wie, hab da jetzt ein paar Kunden und brauch da jetzt so, ab 4000 Adressen oder vielleicht irgendwie ab 2048 Adressen, so in der Größenordnung.
Ja oder zum Beispiel, ich hab pro Tag im Schnitt so und so viele Neukunden und ich brauch genug Adressen für den nächsten Monat. Und ich hab grad nochmal nachgeschaut, selbst wenn man da richtig viele Adressen hat und als extra large gewährt wird, was irgendwie nur 10, 15 Provider in Deutschland sind, sind das nur 5000 Euro im Jahr. Also es sind bei den Beträgen, die man da spielt, um so und so viele IP-Adressen zu verwalten, ist das halt irgendwie Portokasse.
Mhm, allein der Strom schon für die ganzen Server, die du da reinschieben musst da. Also wir hatten ja vorhin, glaubt den, deine Frage, so ein bisschen elegant übergangen, wo du meintest, was es denn so kostet, so ein Rechenzentrum zu betreiben, aber das kommt irgendwie auf die B-Wag an und das kommt auf die...
Na macht ihr selber denn sowas?
Also wir betreiben kein Rechenzentrum, na ja doch. Also wir haben im Berliner Club im Keller einen Raum, der war früher mal ein Rechenzentrum. Da standen mehr Racks drinnen, eine Klimaanlage und so weiter. Aber inzwischen ist das auch alles, weil sich das nicht mehr rentiert, das selbst zu betreiben. Ist das inzwischen nur noch irgendwie ein Rack mit zwei, drei Servern drin und das war's. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel in einem Rechenzentrum einen Rack angemietet und dort legen wir unser eigenes Internet hin und verwalten das. Und da haben wir auch die eigenen Server drin stehen. Und da ziehen wir in dem Fall von dem Rechenzentrum, beziehen wir nur den Strom und die Standfläche für das Rack. Und ich glaube, da sind wir inzwischen bei so 26, 28 Cent die Kilowattstunde oder 30 sogar.
Okay, aber da hat ja keiner Hausnummer zu sagen, was das im Monat kostet insgesamt. Das finde ich halt immer das Spannende bei diesen Geschichten, weil letztlich die Frage, die nicht steht immer ist, auch kann ich das selber machen? Und dann scheint ja vor allem eine Kostenfrage zu sein.
Ich kann dir sagen, ich habe da so bei einem Provider in Dürrenberg, glaube ich, steht hier, habe ich mir einen Server angemietet und da bezahle ich da so, das heißt irgendwie auch noch der Traffic mit dabei. Aber so Stromkosten haben wir gesagt, das ist wie so knapp unter 30 Euro im Monat.
Ja, also du zahlst so 20 Euro an Strom im Monat für einen leistungsstarken Server, wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie einen Strom sparen, also in den Stromkosten ist halt meist die Kühlung drin, weil so irgendwie Hälfte, zwei Drittel, die du an Strom in den Server reinschiebst, kommen als Wärme wieder raus.
Hey, super. Aber zurück zum RIPE das kümmert sich also um die IP-Adressenvergabe und ihr habt gerade gesagt, das ist ein Verein mehr oder weniger und besteht aus zwei Teilen. Der eine, der Dinge beschließt, der andere, der es dann umsetzen muss. Wer ist in diesem Verein drin? Also bei den Rechenzentren haben wir gelernt, da tun sich einfach sozusagen die Leute zusammen, die in der Gegend da mehr oder weniger großes Interesse an so Technik haben. Wer ist das RIP?
Also im RIPE das ist die Community, das sind in Europa ISPs. Und zwar, wenn man halt ISP ist und dann die Größe erreicht, wo man eigene IP-Adressen haben will und auch beantragen möchte, dann wird man so genannte Loan, das steht für Local Internet Registrar. Das ist dann nochmal eine Unterart von dem Regional Internet Registrar wie die RIPE. Und da mit dem Mitglied werden, kauft man sich das Recht, die Adressen zu beantragen und man darf abstimmen. Dann in der RIPE betreibt man halt mehrere Mailing-Listen über die verschiedensten Themen, unter anderem zum Beispiel auch, wie diese Adressen vergeben werden. Dort wird dann über das Jahr in bestimmten Prozessen irgendwie halt entschieden, dass da jetzt ein Proposal, also ein Vorschlag für Regeln gemacht wird, über den dann zweimal im Jahr auf so einem Meeting abgestimmt wird. Also wenn da dann durchdiskutiert wurde, es keine Widersprüche gab und so weiter und so weiter, kommt es dann, wo es bei so einem General Meeting nennt sich das, also da treffen sich dann die ganzen Leute auf so einem Meeting und stimmen dann darüber ab, einen Tag lang, ob das angenommen wird. Und wenn es tatsächlich angenommen wird, wird dann dieses Regelwerk so gesagt, was dann halt sagt, weil jemand die Sachen vergibt, an das RIPE NCC gegeben. Die haben dann Angestellte, die dann halt nichts anderes machen, als Mails lesen, drin steht, ich brauch so und so viel IP-Adressen. Dann schauen sie, dass alles, ob das nach Policy-Konform so okay ist. Und wenn es okay ist, geben sie den Leuten dann die IP-Adressen.
Okay, das hört sich ja sehr gradlinig an, kaum kompliziert, wo man sagen muss, Beschlussfassung von mehreren Teilnehmern über Policy-Vorschläge sind wahrscheinlich große.
In Europa sind es, glaube ich, 5.000 Mitglieder und auf diesen Mailinglisten hast du so irgendwie, wenn es viel zu diskutieren gibt, sind das halt auch mal 50 oder 100 Mails am Tag. Und das ist schon, also wenn man damit halten will, ist das viel Mail lesen und in die Diskussion mitdiskutieren.
Ich muss jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch mal den boulevardesken Typen raushängen lassen, weil jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen, und das finde ich, also ich zumindest habe viel verstanden, erklärt, wie das Internet funktioniert auf einer Business-Ebene quasi. Jetzt sind ja die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club meistens auch damit beschäftigt, so Dinge auseinanderzunehmen oder zumindest mal hinzugucken und zu sagen, das ist aber da ein bisschen komisch und könnte uns möglicherweise mal auf die Füße fallen. Das habe ich jetzt bei den ganzen Sachen noch nicht so richtig gehört. Ist da etwa alles in Ordnung?
Eigentlich ist das alles super dezentral, aber es gibt natürlich überall irgendwie Haken an der Sache. Zum Beispiel gab es das mal vor mehreren Jahren. Da gab es also ein Großteil setzt halt irgendwie zum Beispiel Cisco-Router ein. Das ist eine Firma aus den USA, die stellt Netzwerkeräte her. Und wenn da ein bestimmtes Paket durchgeschickt wurde, haben die sich alle irgendwie intern aufgehangen und mussten resettet werden. Und das nannte man dann so den Flap Around the World, weil halt wirklich einmal um die ganze Welt rum, diese Router geflapt sind, da hat es dann einmal ordentlich gewackelt im Internet. Oder wenn halt ein so ein großer Exchange irgendwie mal Schluck auf hat, wo halt richtig viel rüberläuft in Europa, dann merkt man das schon. Aber so der Endkunde, der denkt dann am Ende mal, Facebook geht gerade nicht. Oder das YouTube Video legt, er lädt langsam. Also der Endkunde bekommt das in der Regel überhaupt nicht mit, was da passiert. Aber es ist so aufgebaut irgendwie, dass da eigentlich ein Ausfall, zum Beispiel, klassischer Fall, ein Bagger baggert so ein Glasfaserkabel kaputt. Innerhalb von Millisekunden ist der Traffic, dann wird woanders lang geleitet und fließt irgendwie von Düsseldorf nach Amsterdam über Düsseldorf, Berlin, Hamburg, Amsterdam.
Es ist ja aber trotzdem so, das sind alles zum allergrößten Teil Privatfirmen, die das machen, also Kapitalisten. Und es ist ja oft so, wenn das pure Business regiert, dass die Infrastruktur, die für solche Dinge verwendet wird, sehr hart kalkuliert ist, also nicht sehr ausfallsicher.
Ja, es gibt halt Firmen, die sehen sich daraus halt irgendwie, wir sind jetzt richtig gut und bei uns kostet alles ein bisschen mehr. Dafür haben wir irgendwie alles doppelt und dreifach gesichert. Und wenn jetzt irgendwie halb Europa stromlos ist, dann haben wir immer noch die andere Hälfte und können mit Amerika reden und so Sachen. Und das lässt sich dann einfach kosten, aber gibt's alles.
Du brauchst diese Art Reputation, dann auch wenn du Banken versorgst, wenn du da irgendwie so seriöse Businesspartner hast, kannst du da nicht einfach dahergehen und sagen, ich hab jetzt aller billigste Netze in mir grad zusammengeschlüppelt und dann ist es dann halt im Großteil der Zeit nicht erreichbar. Und aber auch die Geschichte des Internets, wie die so gewachsen ist, ist auch so, dass dort viele, viele Engineers immer mit dabei gewesen sind, irgendwie auch prinzipbedingt, weil dieses Thema auch dann ein bisschen trocken ist und erstaunlich wenig Leute, die einfach nur Geld dran verdienen wollten, im Laufe der Zeit gerade an der Kerninfrastruktur da beteiligt waren. Es gab viele, viel Konkurrenz einfach aus den Forschungsnetzen. Das heißt, dass zu der Zeit auch Wissenschaftler am meisten daran interessiert waren, ihre Universitäten, an denen ja auch die Computer dann standen, die wenigen, die miteinander hätten sprechen wollen, dass die dann auch schon untereinander dann eher dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Kabel verbuddelt werden und auch dort die verpeilten Wissenschaftler noch ans andere Ansprüche an die Verdrahtung hatten, als jemand, der jetzt seine Endkunden da anschließen möchte. Und auch viel kam ja aus der Post heraus. In Deutschland waren es damals nicht die Leute, die möglichst viel Geld verdienen wollten, sondern es saß dann auch mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen, die so ein beschnurbarteter Telekom früher Posttechnikgehalt hatte. Der wollte aber auch dann ein gutes Produkt abliefern, was dann halt auch ein bisschen teurer und ein bisschen unbeweglicher war. Aber so war die Geschichte des Netzes zumindest in Deutschland auch. Dann früher, dass sie das erklären, warum dann auch nicht ganz viele böse spielen. Aber es gibt jetzt auch, gerade bei den neueren CDN, gibt es auch welche, die dann wirklich mit harten Bandagen da reinmienen und sehen, dass da irgendwie noch Geld rauszusqueezen ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel diese, also die Redundanz, die man da halt baut, das als ausfallsicher ist, das rechnet sich halt einfach dadurch, weil wenn jetzt zum Beispiel in Berlin zweimal am Tag das Internet ausfällt oder sowas, dann dauert das irgendwie, dann gehen die Kunden ja automatisch weg, weil es doof ist.
Damit der S-Bahn tun sie es aber auch nicht.
Ja, nur bei der S-Bahn hat man glaube ich nicht so anruf, obwohl man könnte auf Helikopter oder Beam umsteigen, aber ja, beim Internet hat man halt die Wahl und wenn man scheiße ist, dann gehen halt die Leute da weg und man verliert Kunden. Deswegen schauen da alle schon, dass das einigermaßen gut ist und je nachdem, was für Kunden es sind, in dem Fall zum Beispiel bei Banken, da muss das alles irgendwie genau geregelt, dass die Glasfasern irgendwie es zwei Verbindungen zwischen den Rechenzentren gibt und an keiner Stelle dürfen sich die Kabel näher kommen als 100 Meter oder so. Also es ist ganz genau geregelt, wie das alles ist, damit das möglichst ausfallsicher läuft.
Also tatsächlich müssten wir sozusagen keine Angst um unser Internet haben, weil das kaputtzumachen ist schon eher schwierig.
Da gab's mal sogar einen, ich glaub, einen längeren Text darüber, wo irgendjemand meinte, was passiert wohl, wenn wir jetzt mit das Internet rum runternehmen wollen und dann hat er dann gesagt, ja dazu müsste man eigentlich nur irgendwie sich sämtliche Landestellen der Kabel, die unterseeisch ankommen. Die sind zwar versteckt, weiß keiner so genau, wo das ist, aber kriegt man raus und dann fing er an und dann wurde es plötzlich so ein zehnseitiger Round, was man alles gleichzeitig machen müsste, wie viele Leute man dafür aktivieren müsste. Wenn man 50.000 Leute gleichzeitig auf der Welt dazu anstiften könnte, das Internet ausschalten zu wollen, dann wäre das ganz einfach.
Gut, dann haben wir heute ausführlich geklärt, wie das Internet geldmäßig funktioniert. Wir haben zum Schluss noch einen Anrufer, der nämlich nicht genau weiß, wer es ist. Hallo und guten Abend. Und? Kannst du mir noch ganz kurz eine Frage beantworten?
Ja, na nicht eine Frage, sondern ich möchte deine Frage beantworten. Ich habe jetzt nicht mehr, ich arbeite bei einer Firma in Berlin, die ein Rechenzentrum hat. Ich habe jetzt leider nicht mehr genau die Stromkosten im Kopf, zumindest nicht vom Rechenzentrum, aber von den Verstärkerstationen. Kann man sich das so vorstellen, man braucht ja verschiedene Verstärkerstationen, 30 Stück sind das in Deutschland bei uns. Und dafür braucht jeder so im Schnitt 10.000 Euro nur an Strom.
Im Monat oder im Jahr? Im Monat. Wow! Wie viel Rechner habt ihr dann, in dem Rechenzentrum zu stehen?
Das ist schon eine ernste Menge. Das müsste ich jetzt durchzählen.
Du hast den Rechenzentrumsnamen mit einer 3 auf.
Gut, Fachleute unter sich, das wollen wir wahrscheinlich nicht im Radio genauer besprechen, worum es gerade geht.
Du bist gerade auf dem Weg von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Was hast du für ein Spleisgerät?
Ich würde vorschlagen, über diese Detail Details haltet ihr euch außerhalb. Tobias, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Das war nochmal ein schöner Hausnummer, die es gut ist gehört zu haben. So, sehr schön. 10.000 Euro Luftwerte, okay, das ist schon viel Strom. So, Erdgeist, Kay, vielen Dank von Chaos Computer Club, die mir erklärt haben, wie das mit dem Geld ist. Ihr könnt, wenn ihr noch Fragen dazu habt oder Bemerkungen, die gerne ins Blog schreiben, chaosradio.de ist die Adresse, die funktioniert jetzt wieder und ist bestimmt total ausfallsicher.
Wir machen nach dem nächsten CDN raus, wenn jemand zu mir kommt, oder?
Ist klar. So, dann wünsche ich euch allen vielen Dank fürs Hiersein, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören euch von Radiogeräten. Wie gesagt, wenn ihr Fragen habt, stellt sie. Um nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter, macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.